zoom platform
or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general pro website
notice of this meeting complies with
rules and rsa 91-10
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271-3600
or email
hcs
in the event the public is unable to
access the
meeting will be adjourned to be
scheduled
i want to introduce the staff
that are on the meeting assisting us
brad greenland the committee researchers
please note that all votes
that are that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by a roll call
let's start to meet by taking a roll
call attendance
and each
member states their presence please also
state whether there's anyone in the room
with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know wall
this time the clerk will not call the
rules
yeah
representative burke
representative hopper
representative greene here
representative wallace
representative testerman yes
representative true president
representative pratt
representative marston
president
clerk is present representative harriet
gathright president
representative pandalakis
president
representative
president home alone
representative jordane
president alone
representative muse
representative newman
president alone in the room my wife is
in the house
representative horrigan
president um alone alone at home in
durham
representative conley
representative klein knight
representative bradley
chairman addis
[Music]
is representative
planning on attending today because
both
both technical assistants are
oh wow
so
just just pointing that out there let me
just
let's let's see what's you know
at this time
excuse me
representative marshall when i'll lead
us in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states
this time we will call we will now open
the public hearing
on senate bill 40
act relative to an important consent to
search the motor vehicle
and many potential requirements for a
search warrant
the chair now recognizes senator french
to interview senate bill ford
good morning mr chair and
the entire committee
my name is harold french senator from
district seven i'm here to present to
you today senate bill 40
an act relative to
to search a motor vehicle
this bill is a very similar if not exact
initially
exact bill of one that was started in
the house
as you
or many of you know
uh oftentimes bills are started both in
the house and in the senate
each line
to make sure
we have at least two bites of the apple
if necessary
so this one was passed through your
committee
and is now in front of your house
version is in front of my committee over
in the senate
and
this varies
very little
from the one you issued to us except
you'll notice
the changes the amendment do you have
that before you
so that is a that amendment
is a request from the courts
in order to amend statutory requirements
for a search warrant
and it allows consistency with the
requirements for electronic warrants
it changes the verbiage
from affidavit to win statement under
oath
that's the gist of the bill any
questions
hey yes thank you
very much
for a question
yes thank you mr chair and uh thank you
uh senator my question i guess i'm just
trying to understand you said that the
uh
verbiage of written statement change is
that
what the court has requested
yes
and did they
shoot me follow up
first over here
and did they give you any particular
reason why that uh
written statement under oath was uh
better than the affidavit
uh they said it was similar and it would
streamline the process for them
in the court system today i don't know
if they're on board to testify to you or
not behind me
okay thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question i don't
have a copy of that amendment senator
can you give me the amendment number
um well it comes through if you pull
it's uh senate bill 40 as amended and
passed by the senate okay
you
okay
see seeing no hands right i want to
thank the senator for his testimony
thank you all very much we'll be seeing
you soon
if there are any members of the public
who are in attendance that wish to
testify
at this time please raise your hand
it's time that china recognizes richard
um
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch uh speaking in favor
of part two of senate bills
which deals with the search warrant form
this was uh a request as senator french
said of the judicial branch
it was added on to his bill as unrelated
to part one of the bill
um but it was added in after the um
after the court did a study evaluation
of the warren process and one of the
recommendations out of that
was to become what's called siegis
compliant the criminal justice
information system
which sets a baseline standard for
security in various aspects of law
enforcement including search warrants
and one of the aspects of that was to
a recommendation
the
law enforcement convert to using the law
enforcement enterprise portal leap
which is hosted by the fbi it provides a
secure remote and telephonic warrant
system
and does so at no cost to the state
so essentially what what we want to move
towards is a more secure process
and one of the elements of that is
to eliminate the
the telephonics oath process that is
currently in place and authorized by new
hampshire statute
but in order to become more sieges
compliant the the goal is to have the
warrant itself be self um
a
self-sworn document so it doesn't
require
a telephonic access which which in off
hours can involve cell phones or other
communications which are not as secure
as other forms of communication
so this allows
the document instead of doing it with an
affidavit and a swearing
that the
the document itself becomes
self-executing it is still a statement
under oath
it does not require a separate swearing
process
with a judge
so essentially the the for it's a change
to the form that is that exists by
statute uh and it makes those changes so
that it no longer would have to be
through an affidavit but would be a
written statement under oath
that is signed by the executing officer
um so it's it's a process that came out
of a review that the court did with
prosecutors and um
in this
and the attorney general's office
involved in that with that i'd be happy
to answer any questions
seeking your hands raised the witnesses
excused thank you thank you very much
at this time the chair recognizes
uh chief david goldstein
[Music]
representative uh just so you know
representative burke is not present
today so you are the only
technical assistant so just uh
try to be uh aware of the
attendees pay hands up if you have a
list of
these
assignments to testify
you don't
i'll do that
good morning mr chairman can you hear me
all right
yes we can hear you oh thank you uh yes
uh for the record my name is uh david
goldstein i'm presently the police chief
uh in the city of franklin and i have
been a police officer for 41 years
uh i signed in late last night
and i signed in as neutral for the
the
new hampshire association of chiefs of
police and we sincerely appreciate the
work that senator french has done on
this and our conversations with him and
we certainly appreciate the since the
intent of the bill but we have just a
very
small concern about some of the language
as drafted
and i'll go right into that first and
foremost relative to that we're we're
suggesting adding the word solely in uh
para one section d
uh which would then read the operator
cannot be further detained solely for
refusing a consent to search
um
the reason for this is because we feel
that
uh if the individual and they have every
right to decides that we should not have
they won't consent to a search let's say
of a motor vehicle does that mean that
as we're walking around the vehicle we
see blood dripping from the trunk does
that mean we have to cease any and all
contact with that individual in further
investigation so we feel by adding that
word um we can forestall any of that
i would like to offer just by way of
some quick information and background
that there are oftentimes circumstances
and
quite frankly when law enforcement
officers wouldn't be doing their jobs by
beta by um detaining individuals and
investigating further
um
and even after first contact with an
individual should something else be
observed it's very important that we
follow through with that um
we were going to testify on uh power on
section two however we understand where
the courts are coming from and certainly
we have no problem with that
uh quite frankly there are numerous
there's no real law pertaining to um
any consent searches or what have you in
fact the united states constitution
doesn't even mention the word privacy uh
it's actually established through the
bill of rights and through a number of
examples of case law
and
we can ask for consent and of the four
police departments that i have served
over 41 years each and every department
has
a form that
informs an individual that they have a
constitutional right not to have their
vehicle premises themselves searched if
you will and certainly there are certain
exceptions that the supreme court has
recognized over the years
we have uh decades of legal decisions
between both state and federal courts
relative to this and we feel that in
many many cases this uh the discretion
should be left to the courts as to
whether or not the uh police officer has
overstepped his or her bounds in
conducting a search so with that i'll
end my testimony and certainly i'm happy
to answer any questions the committee
might have
seen no hands raised i want to take it
with us for a second
thank you
this time
what you can recognize is
by sheer
uh
thank you mr chair uh thank you members
of the committee
i uh i've been in front of the committee
several times so i won't
give you a lengthy introduction nice as
i'm required to say
uh the opinions i expressed today are
solely mine they're not the opinions of
the law school or of unh proper um
um i i worked both with senator french
and representative roy on each of their
bills representative roy was the prime
sponsor uh of hb 485 which uh is in the
senate and before the senate judiciary
committee right now
i am obviously in support of sb40 i
think it's a good idea um i'm not going
to repeat uh what i said to this
committee when i testified in favor of
hb 485
i refer the committee to my written
comments in favor of
sb485 i would point out that the
recommendation by chief goldstein to
edward soley i think is a mistake it
puts
there's nothing that he wants to make
sure is protected
that is not
that gets additional protection by
adding the word solely you know i um i i
think uh that confuses the issue and
suggests that
the the police can take into
consideration as a reason for searching
a car
for having probable cause for searching
a car that the person refused to consent
and that is not under the us
constitution and case law that is not
appropriate that is the unintended
effect of adding the word solely in
there so i think uh i think as written
the uh
uh
sb40 is uh is well-worded and um
i uh you know i
i think as i said in front of the senate
uh i have great respect for both
representative roy and senator french so
i'm not going to pick between the two of
them i don't want to piss either one of
them off for lack of a better way of
putting it
with that more than willing i recommend
you vote ought to pass
willing to answer any questions
representative newman you're recognized
for a question
thank you mr chair i just have a
question about what uh to the witness
thank you for taking the question about
your talking about the word solely
um if a police officer sees something in
a car that is suspicious that there's a
crime and he has probable cause
um what happens in that situation do
they then just have to get a warrant to
search the car or can they take some
action without a warrant uh it depends
uh on the circumstance
uh if
if it's perceived that it meets the
exigent
circumstances
exception uh then they don't need to get
a warrant they
as long as they have probable cause so
blood dripping out of the car from the
trunk would probably meet the exigent
circumstances uh suggested uh if they uh
if otherwise what they would do is they
just detain the car
and get a search warrant um so uh it
depends on the circumstances but
this this bill doesn't get in the way of
that one way or another
representative for a follow-up question
thank you very much mr chair um and
where where is that exigent
circumstances is that in the
constitution state law federal law where
is that
it's uh in uh u.s supreme court and
new hampshire supreme court sequence of
decisions it's a very well established
exception uh to the search warrant
requirement
thank you
you're welcome
we'll note that representative wallace
is now in the president
seeing no no answers i want to thank the
witness first testimony
thank you mr chair
it's time to cheer recognize lisa
good morning um can you all hear
me yes we can hear you thank you thank
you so much for taking my testimony this
morning i had not signed up but um i did
want to
jump in here my name is lissa maccio i
am an attorney with the department of
corrections division of professional
standards i
did hear you all kind of chatting before
this session started particularly
representative rhodes about hb 485 the
the bill that was already came out of
the house i did just want to draw to
your attention
we were working with
representative roy on hb 485 along with
senator carson
although the language of these bills is
not
the same we did want to draw your
attention to a concern the department of
corrections has that was addressed by an
amendment on hb 485
which was actually
addressed in executive session with the
senate judiciary just last night
that amendment is one one two three s um
i did email it to um chairman abbess
yesterday both that amendment um which
representative roy and senator carson
worked on
and our memo both to representative roy
and march and the senate judiciary
committee the concern is really um with
the lack of a carve out in sb40 hb 485
had a section carving out precluding
some specific searches that did not
require consent and that amendment added
an exception for department of
corrections
if you look at the amend
the memo that director cusack drafted
already an administrative rule
specifically cor
305 and 306. the department of
corrections does have the ability to
search without consent or even warning
vehicles possessions and persons that
are on doc
property and it really is a matter of
public safety and security of the
facilities that doc be able to do that
so i did just want to draw your
attention to that specific issue and the
amendment that was just
passed through the committee in the
senate and i'm happy to try and answer
any questions
seeing no games raised i want to thank
goodness for her testimony thank you so
much
the chair now recognizes
joseph
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is joseph ebert
it's e-b-e-r-t
i'm a captain with the new hampshire
state police i oversee the investigative
services bureau
we are
neutral on this bill however the new
hampshire state police does employ this
process
as we speak a written
waiver for
a search of a motor vehicle
we do after review of this bill have one
area that we would like the committee to
consider and that is under number one
roman numeral two and we would recommend
adding
a statement that is similar to
unless re-engaged by the operator
so what it says is if the person refuses
a consent to search the officer shall uh
which is uh for obvious reasons a very
strong term
shall uh stop questioning about the
consent
my concern as i testified before the
senate as well is that
oftentimes we are re-engaged by the
uh the operator and a situation where
this might come into play is where you
advise the operator okay uh at this time
then i'm going to seize your motor
vehicle and i'm going to apply for a
warrant at which time the operator says
to you oh okay all right well i don't
want you to do that um i have uh you
know maybe a marijuana
joint in the console or
something that could be as little as a
violation level offense that they could
be released on the side of the road with
the summons with
uh so they're they're weighing out their
options and they're saying to you okay
well i don't want you to go through the
the process of towing my vehicle that
that's going to put me out further so
therefore i i want to uh go forward with
the consent church now there's an awful
lot that is documented in a situation
like that to make sure that the person
doesn't feel that they're being coerced
in any way or pressure is
placed upon them and they're they're
making that choice freely however that
entire discussion seems to be precluded
uh by number one roman numeral two
unless there is a statement uh
added to
acknowledge that they could re-engage
the officer
so with that uh that is my testimony for
this morning i'm happy to answer any
questions if you have them
o'hare
thank you mr chair and thank you uh
for taking my question i guess i would
assess the question uh i know you
haven't spoke on it but what would be
your opinion
about the
chief's recommendation uh
it was made earlier on testimony about
the words uh
was it solely
yes sir uh representative o'hara and i
um uh
you know we had not um
in our review saw that but when i heard
uh chief goldstein testified to that it
seemed like uh a common sense addition i
understand that mr shearer disagrees
with that but we would be supportive of
adding the word solely um
as chief goldstein had mentioned
thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to take it
with this first test
thank you
just point out for the record that
representative pogba is now joining us
in the committee room
does any additional members of the
public wish to testify
that anything's please raise your hand
cheers recognizing
devin
good morning mr chair
and other honorable members of the
committee my name is devin chafee and
i'm the executive director of the
american civil liberties union of new
hampshire
and i want to thank you for the
opportunity to testify today in support
of sv40
we are testifying in support of sb40
just as we testified in support of the
house version of this bill hb 485 uh
when it was before your committee and we
just want to thank and give our
appreciation for the committee's uh due
consideration of that bill uh the time
that you put in into passing a sensible
amendment with that bill um which was
then voted uh ought to pass unanimously
out of the committee um and then passed
on on the consent calendar of the full
house
um
we support uh sb 4040 you know we also
do not have strong feelings about
which of these two bills uh are
preferable as far as their language
they're they're very similar they've
accomplished very similar um objectives
uh i do uh want to make clear that we
have no concerns uh with either the
judiciary's uh request in this second um
part of the sb40 as was passed by the
senate as was adopted as a as by
amendment and we also have no concerns
um with the amendment that was proposed
by the department of corrections uh uh
in then that was uh adopted by the
senate judiciary committee as an
amendment to hb 485 yesterday it's a
sensible and limited um amendment
i do want to voice some concerns with
the amendments that have been proposed
in committee for um as far as i know for
the first time today
um
the
the concern with adding the word solely
to section one uh subsection d
of uh of sb40 i i just
i i we have similar concerns
as to the ones that were raised by
professor cher earlier um what adding
the word under the way that the language
is written now
refusing to consent to a search cannot
be considered as as as part of the
reason to detain an individual and that
is right and correct under current case
law as well
if you add the word solely
refusing to consent to a search in
addition to other factors
that that refusal to consent to a search
can be considered as a reason to detain
now as it's written now a person can
still be detained if there is reason to
detain them and there are other factors
beyond the consent to search that that
would lend um the police to need to
detain someone and they they meet the
the necessary requirements that person
can still be detained um but the
refusing to consent a search should not
be a part of that equation
and that is why we feel strongly that
the word solely should not should not be
included in that section
um i i also was was a bit confused by
the uh suggested amendment that was
proposed by the state police
uh right now as it's written if we can
and maybe if we can just read section
two reads if the operator of a motor
vehicle refuses to consent to a search
the law enforcement
officer shall cease any further
questioning
concerning consent to search
there is nothing in that section
currently that prevents an officer from
then re from from speaking with an
individual that that you know that they
have pulled over are in conversation
with if that individual re-engages them
they simply have to cease further
questioning about the consent to search
so i i see no reason why you would you
would need to add anything about
the person being reengaged by the op uh
um
by the uh by the operator of the motor
vehicle if the operator of the motor
vehicle wants to continue that con a
discussion they can certainly do that
the officers simply shall not continue
to pressure that individual by through
questioning about the consent to search
so there's nothing that would prohibit
further conversation if the operator
re-engages the officer
the officer simply has to stop
questioning that person about the
consensus search so i really don't see
the need for that amendment that has
been recommended as well
um
and with that i would simply say you
know we we respectfully urge the members
of this committee to vote to pass on sb
uh sb40 um and and again we do not have
strong feelings about you know the the
language on sb40 versus uh hb 485 um you
know other than to simply to let the
flag for the committee that the senate
judiciary committee yesterday did vote
ought to pass with amendment on hb 485
so that will likely be going to the
senate floor next week thank you so much
thank you mr chair and it's just a
question about the last part that was
said about the uh questioning somebody
about the consent to search and the word
solely
um if the word solely was in there and
you want and the person changed their
mind which was the example given
would would you consider that those
additional questions then about that
consent to search is is allowed by the
language that we have here
i i i have to be honest um
representative i wasn't sure that i
fully understood the example that was
given um if if the uh
it's the
my understanding is that there's nothing
in this currently that prohibits the
officer from re-engaging in a
conversation with the operator
um i i don't understand why that
exchange would be prohibited by the
language that that is there in the way
that i understood the example as it was
presented
thank you
i want to thank the witness for our
testimony
we will note for the record that
representative colony has now physically
joined us on the road
if there's any members of the public who
wish to testify there that are in
attendance that have not testified
already
this time please raise your hand
see no uh for other hands raised at this
time
we'll close the public hearing on senate
bill 40.
mr chair we had a number of people
signing in we had 77 uh people sign in
in support of the bill
we had one person sign in in opposition
and we had another person who signed in
is neutral
we will be
recess to 9 45.
representative panel lochus has her
handwriting not sure if she wants to ask
yes
mr chairman
could i ask a question
if do we have any second committee bills
for house bills
yes
i don't i don't believe so there's not
least there's none that's been assigned
there was two uh second committee bills
that were signed but those were waived
off
they were waged off yes during the
session
in february
i thank you
at this time
the criminal justice publication
committee will be open to public
hearings
on the senate bill 110 an act relative
to animal motor vehicles
and this time the chair recognizes
yeah i'll take it
we can
just down the year will recognize
senator sherman we introduce senate bill
one day
mr chair
good morning
good good morning are you able to hear
me
yes we can hear you okay great thank you
for the record uh my name is tom sherman
state senator district 24
11 towns on the seacoast
and i appreciate
the opportunity to introduce sb 110
which is uh an act relative to animals
and motor vehicles
as
many of us who have been in the
legislature for several years know this
is a
an effort that keeps coming back
and my goal
this bill was brought to my attention or
this effort was brought to my attention
by a young high school student
named olivia hammer who i believe is
able to testify
um
who had great concern about animals
being left in cars with the windows up
and during the summer
and the inability of anybody to act
so
this version of the bill
is quite different from prior versions
and
i credit the attorney general's office
and others for helping me come up with a
solution to the this
recurrent concern
um
and the um
the
concern is the the solution is
essentially and i'll use quotes around
this word to deputize
the person who would like to intervene
so if you're in a shopping mall parking
lot
and you see a dog
that's in extremis or or a cat for that
matter that's in the extremis inside a
car
what you are able to do is actually get
in touch with law enforcement and with a
witness present law enforcement can
authorize you
whether you use a smartphone or however
you uh are able to
get your message across to law
enforcement that that an intervention is
needed they can't get there in time
they can authorize you to go ahead and
act
and in my knowledge this is the first
time that the american kennel club has
actually signed on in support of a bill
that stacey ober on the senate side when
we heard the bill when we presented the
bill on the senate side
this version was amended in the senate
to clarify that this is not just any
animal that's confined anywhere but this
is within a vehicle
um
and
um so it's very specific uh you cannot
take action uh without the blessing of
law enforcement
and a witness
um and that is what makes this very
different um
and it provides
the indemnification
under roman four
but you have to be authorized by law
enforcement so that's why this is has
been able to move forward as opposed to
prior bills that did not have that
what i like to call deputization
component
so with that i'm happy to take any
questions that you might have
thank you senator for your testimony if
the chair would like to acquire the
question
but
under six under roman numeral three
section b it says that
in addition to the law enforcement
officer
another witness or individual has to be
present
what's the rationale for having an
enough
another witness present
if you're already authorized by law
enforcement i suppose what's the reason
for having that
actually yeah actually the reason for
the witness
is
um
you know
uh basically it's it's in a way it's
protection for the law enforcement
law enforcement to
be able to know that there's another
person on the scene who can verify the
situation
uh and is willing to
certify
as a witness to the situation so that
you know law enforcement isn't depending
on one person's word
they are um
and
and they do have that way they would
have
i guess the best way to say it is
back up documentation that the law
enforcement authorization was
appropriate
so it really is there and and this was
part of the discussion
you know this was a
2020 bill that was a victim of covid so
this discussion took place
about a year and a half ago or a year
ago at least
and this was the way to be sure that
there was adequate documentation that
the situation was what it was and
so when law enforcement authorized it
they would have the ability
to
call a witness if they needed to to say
yes who could then say yes i was there i
saw the interaction and
that's the reason for that additional
person being being brought into the
authorization
thank you process taking my question
[Music]
representative rhodes you recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so
my question is if you're if you see this
you know there's an animal in a car stay
in a parking lot
and the person calls 911
there's a witness present should it be
written in the law that that person and
witness needs to remain there until law
enforcement arrives so that
they're able to law enforcement at least
able to try to
find the owner of the vehicle and or be
there when the person comes out because
if my concern is the person coming out
their car window is broken
the police aren't there yet or the
police are there
to
you know
kind of protect that person from
the hostile person that may be walking
up to their broken window
right i i um
i absolutely would be would welcome an
amendment that that asked the witness to
remain until law enforcement arrived
uh i i think that's a good suggestion
and um
you know it it makes it a little bit
more difficult
if they are not willing you know if they
say sure i'll stick around and then they
take off
but the idea is that that witness you
know we have to have a name
contact information
before
law enforcement would authorize so i
think even even if they did leave
um
they would uh you know they would still
be able to be contacted but
i i think it's a great suggestion and
i'd be open to it
representative road you recognize for a
follow-up thank you so just to clarify
that the
an officer is going to go to the sea
if this is necessary to have happen
i
yes thank you um
that would be the expectation um
you know these
this situation uh where law enforcement
uh can't get there in time i i think
many people have
had that frustrating moment when they've
seen a car compliant
animal confined in the car
and can't you know they don't know what
to do um
this
the expectat the problem is of course
that
um
whether law enforcement could actually
get there in time if the animal is
unresponsive or anything like that so
uh yes the expectation would be that if
law enforcement uh authorizes that
action i i mean
my understanding would be that they
would be coming one way or the other
the question is can they get there in
time and if they can't get there in time
then
it would be important for them to be
able to authorize the person on the
scene to act to protect the animal
so they they have to be called in any
event
thank you
chair recognizes representative my night
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um senator
have you
asked any police officers in the state
of new hampshire if they feel
comfortable with deputizing a citizen
without being there and witnessing and
being a part of what's going on to see
exactly
if they should be putting their own
careers at risk thank you
absolutely
we've talked to law enforcement on this
bill
remember there's no requirement that
they do this so this is i guess the best
word this is enabling
but the law enforcement if they don't
feel comfortable they don't deputize so
this would have to be a willing law
enforcement officer who
looks at the situation either through a
smartphone or otherwise and says yes you
can go ahead but there is
no pressure
no liability for law enforcement if they
say no we're not going to authorize them
they don't authorize
representatives you're recognized for a
follow-up
thank you um
so you've talked to many law enforcement
officers that would be okay deputizing
citizens
i've talked to law enforcement
officers who are okay with this wording
that doesn't require them to deputize
anyone
so
those that are willing to deputize
this this bill the original language was
i talked to as i said the attorney
general's office
and i talked to law enforcement and
they're comfortable with the language
because it leaves it up to law
enforcement
what they are willing or not willing to
do
uh and and there is no you know there's
no requirement there's no liability for
law enforcement no additional liability
the standard of practice is that they
go to the scene
and this allows them
to be there remotely
through uh the person who has called
them if they so choose
just as an additional
the law enforcement has already
expressed to me
that they find these situation
frustrating because they know something
has to be done and they can't get there
in time so
that you know this makes it as flexible
as possible for law enforcement without
any additional requirements
the chair recognizes representative
hughes for a question
thank you for taking my question
would a dispatcher uh be authorized as a
law enforcement officer under this bill
or would a dispatcher actually need to
find a sworn officer uh in order uh to
be able to get permission to do this i'm
just curious about how that would work
since a lot of the calls that come into
police departments aren't actually taken
by officers directly
that's that's a great question and so
my understanding of how this works is
that the call would come into dispatch
dispatch would call
law enforcement and um
they do have the capacity to have direct
contact with the person who called in
they can have you hold on the line while
they contact the officer they're
dispatching they're going to be
dispatching an officer one way or the
other if there's an animal in distress
in the car and and that connection uh in
fact
in a recent experience
health related
i was able to talk to law enforcement on
their way so
it you know we are
beautifully connected nowadays and so
this would be but dispatch would never
be put in the position
of making this kind of decision this
would be up to the
the officer who has been dispatched by
dispatch
thank you
the channel recognizes representative
trump for a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question senator
i'm trying to envision how how this law
would
work um
this is going to be my car in the
example
and my dog is asleep in the car and a
concerned citizen
feels
the dog is in danger
i don't like i can't imagine a police
officer
authorizing somebody to to break into my
car
because they feel
that the dog is in danger i mean it's
not like
it's not like a an expert or a an animal
control officer is watching
um i'm just
i'm trying to envision
me coming out of a shopping center
my my dog who was sleeping is now awake
and my car's window is broken
and no one is liable
for that situation
because a concerned citizen thought they
were doing the right thing
can you see that problem
arising
um well
that's always possible i mean that could
happen now uh i think
the it's interesting because
speaking with
uh trial attorneys on this issue
[Music]
they actually opposed the original bill
which they have always opposed in the
past and they are
okay with this
this one this version
because of the protections put in there
through law enforcement that
what they did say was that
um
while
you as the
angry car owner which i completely get
um
would
you know would be able to
bring suit or have some
um you know demanding that the window be
replaced or or whatever
uh
very few their comment was
that
very few few people if the person who
broke the window was acting in good
faith right now with no additional
authorization it would be very hard for
you to to bring suit or otherwise
you know there's there's a lot of things
to think about not just your broken
window there's suppose you had a dog
that has a history of biting
and somebody breaks the window thinking
they're being a good samaritan
um right now they can do that if they
think the dog's in distress and that dog
might then bite them
or get loose to the risk of that
of that dog
and
that would be
very you know that that would be
uh dangerous for the public and
otherwise that's why putting
this gives an alternative
where law enforcement is called they you
know they pretty much have to be called
and they can put the brakes on the whole
thing they can say no i'm you know three
minutes away
we can wait until i'm there
or they can say you know i'm
tied up with something it's going to be
20 minutes and they can question the
person they can say you know what kind
of collar does the dog have on do they
have a muzzle on
is there drool coming out of their mouth
have you tried banging on the window to
see if the dog is arousable have you
done
so
in a way this is actually a speed bump
in the in the road towards somebody
acting
in what they think is good faith and
what may actually put themselves in the
public at risk
that's the reason why these kind of
bills have been previously
opposed
and that's also why this bill is
actually rather than
being something in my opinion and in the
opinion of many others this bill
actually
um
keeps people from
acting on their own
it clarifies in what setting
would there be
any kind of indemnity
and
it um really puts a pretty hard
um
stop on the process of people breaking
people's windows or trying to get into a
car
or even opening the door if the door
isn't locked
you know all those things we hope will
be avoided unless there is really really
strong evidence
that that animal is
in extremis and
and that's where law enforcement has
some expertise
most of the law enforcement officers
that i've spoken to
have been in this situation before
they've been called they know what to do
and they're not going to deputize
somebody
lightly for all the reasons that you all
have brought up with your great
questions
so
my belief is that this makes the
situation actually more controlled
and
safer than it currently is where people
are acting on their own
the go-to person is law enforcement if
this bill were to pass
and that's the safest
in all worlds
you
[Music]
representative o'hare and you were
recognized for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question um so section b
is only
in the absence that the officer is not
on scene
correct yes this this would
this would not
uh well i guess if the officer is on the
scene i can't imagine
why
what the situation would be where an
officer on the scene would ask somebody
else to take action but
um
but
this
unless the officer needs help and then
they can authorize somebody to help them
um it would uh i hadn't thought of that
but it would allow the officer to say
look you have my authorization to help
me out here
and and i'm trying to think of a
situation where that would be the case
but it does allow the officer to
authorize somebody to assist them
follow
up o'hara and you're recognized for a
follow-up question
so
but if the officer wasn't there and
the
person um
i guess speaking with the officer
would have that person would also again
have to find an another person to
witness it
yeah but would you believe that uh
not all witnesses will stay around and
wait for the police to arrive
yes and so
the only way this individual
has any protection
is if they are authorized by a police
officer and they have that witness i i
like the idea
of qualifying
documentation on that
we losing
can you hear me
you know
yeah i'm sorry so what i was saying um
hopefully are you able to hear me okay
you know
yeah
so
what that
um
person
um what the
i like the idea of further qualifying
the requirements on the witness
uh that that they have to stay around
until law enforcement is there and that
to qualify as a witness the person has
to have their contact information or
however you want to word it but
the the benefit of that of course is
what we've talked about is that if
the person cannot act if they don't have
all the information
regarding that witness
[Music]
he's a senator
hello
are you able to hear me hello
representative fine knight we generally
have been limiting
members of two questions for witness uh
we will allow an exception for this this
time
thank you chair thank you senator for
taking another question
is there currently an actual process in
law that police officers have to follow
as like a sort of checklist before
they themselves break into
a car for an animal and if that is a
current process
would you be open to putting that and as
amended or amend this to include
a certain series of checkpoints
that have to be followed
yeah so the answer to the first part of
the question is i don't know um what law
enforcement whether they have
any codified steps they have to follow
before they can enter another person's
vehicle
and the answer is i would be absolutely
open to an amendment that would
require the authorized person to follow
the same steps
if they exist
gabriel you're recognized for a question
here um
my question is
it's thinked here that um
an individual may take action to rest
rest for an animal combined with the
vehicle endangered
extreme temperatures
um can you define extreme temperatures
for me
well
hmm that's a good question
extreme temperatures it can vary uh
you can have a an animal confined in a
car if it's sunny out uh
even if it's
you know 75 80 degrees if it's sunny the
interior of the car
may heat up very rapidly
and i think we all have know that from
our own personal experience
so
that is a judgment call um
the uh the other possibility is that
it's you know rare but it happens in new
hampshire that's over 100 degrees out
and
and the car is closed up and
you know the car's not on the air
conditioning is not on and
that pretty is pretty straightforward so
the ambient outdoor temperature is not
the qualifier here the
the qualifier is what's going on inside
the car and
[Music]
so
if the car is closed on a sunny day and
it may be as i said the ambient
temperature may be 75 80 but the
temperature in that car is well over 100
that would be
an extreme temperature in my book
representative o'hare
you recognize
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking another question i'm just
going to
play i guess devil's advocate off of
representative uh harriet catherine's
question extreme temperatures could also
i guess be considered uh cold weather
would it not
sure could and um
uh
you know again the idea of it
certainly we we have those days as you
know sir that that it can get well below
zero
uh
animals are better equipped than we are
for that kind of weather but a dog or a
cat stuck in a car for
an hour or more uh in sub-zero weather
may suffer from that so yes that's a
good question
and up
and senator would you believe that
my previous
experience was in law enforcement and
during my period time there i've
experienced
numerous times of going calls to dogs
in cars and have learned over the years
that
even dogs that
short hair to long hair um
are affected differently and
um
the average person probably would not
have that knowledge
would you believe right and
and uh thank you for that
observation because that's exactly why
this depends on law enforcement for any
kind of authorization
representative muse you
recognized thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking another question from me
um
one of the things that i'm curious about
is whether or not we actually have a
similar law in the books uh for children
um as i sort of quickly look through our
statutes it looks like uh it's legal to
leave a child in an unattended vehicle
in new hampshire
uh and i'm just curious if you know if
an officer is facing the same situation
with a child
could or a person who on the street who
walks by and notice uh notices a child
in distress in a hot car
would they actually run into uh similar
sorts of
liability issues that this law is
attempting to address
uh
i i i just i'm sorry representative i
just don't know the answer to your
question
um i'm happy to do some
digging on it and find out what the
situation is i think it's a little
clearer though if it's a human whether
it's a child or an elderly adult or
otherwise
anyone
or a disabled adult who can't extract
themselves from a dangerous environment
i do think there there is protection
there but um
i i can't answer that with
concrete knowledge this is this bill
does not address that of course
yes i just want to say that i i don't
think uh
all laws can address uh all situations
but um this particular bill uh does
raise an interesting question in that
area
thank you
see no
representative green you're recognized
mr speaker uh representative
representative chairman uh senator
sherman i have a question
uh line two effective day this actually
take effect 60 days after this passage
would you object change that to be
effective as a sign
because we're coming from warm weather
in fact we're already into warm weather
now
right
no i saw as long as there's no rule
making i would have no objection to that
and i i don't think there would be any
rule making required
thank you for thanking my question
see seeing no further hands
raised on thank you center first
testimony
thank you so much for your time i
appreciate it
this time the chair recognizes olivia
hammer
and if there's any members of the public
in attendance that we should testify
that have not testified already please
raise your hands
am i okay to speak
you're recognizing this
okay thank you
good morning my name is olivia hammer
i'm a 17 year old student at the
governor's academy in massachusetts but
i am a new hampshire resident
thank you senator sherman for inviting
me back to support and work toward
helping dogs left in the car without
proper ventilation and without their
owner being present
thank you to the house criminal justice
and public safety committee for taking
the time to listen to my testimony in
support of senate bill 110.
it is timely to be here
to discuss this topic as we approach
another summer in new england
dog lovers and owners do not
intentionally leave their dogs in a car
to harm them it is most likely an error
where they have lost track of time while
running errands i hope this bill
senate bill 110 will allow people like
me and you to have the ability to do
something for a dog that is in distress
without experiencing the possible
negative repercussions of their actions
hopefully this bill will pass to ensure
animal safety and protect the citizen
perhaps most dog owners will be happy
that their dog was aided and saved from
heat exhaustion heat stroke brain damage
and possible death
when we
when we last discussed this bill in
february a senate judiciary member asked
a question about the number of dogs that
have expired last year while being left
in vehicles in new hampshire
although i could not get an accurate
number for the state of new hampshire my
research shows that across the country
31 animal companions have endured
heat-related deaths since 21 2020
however these are the only ones that
were reported according to an article
posted by the people for the ethical
treatment of animals
this specific article includes
descriptions dates and locations of
several avoidable dog deaths
it ends with and i quote
tell lawmakers to take action for kids
and animals left in hot cars
end quote
another valuable source of information
that i found was a statement in the bark
post made by dr katie nelson a
veterinarian in virginia
she said mortality from heat stroke is
approximately 50 percent and it worsens
with every wasted second end quote and
that was relative to dogs
our own nhspcas which stands for new
hampshire society for the prevention of
cruelty to animals website has a hot car
safety photo that states and i quote if
the outside temperature is 75 degrees
the inside temperature of the car is
going to be a much higher 118 degrees
this is too hot for a dog to withstand
for any length of time a dog's normal
temperature is 101.5 to
102.2 degrees and anything above that is
a risk for the dog just as it would be
for a human
the dog does not have to be foaming at
the mouth or showing signs of distress
for the police to take necessary action
the brain is already starting
irreparable damage between 107 and 108
degrees end quote
according to senate bill 110 an
individual may take actions to rescue a
confined animal as long as such
activities are expressly authorized by a
law enforcement officer and witnessed by
another individual
to add maybe it comes down to a specific
protocol that an average citizen can
carry out in the parking lot a list of
actions that a citizen can and must
consider are
obviously contact law enforcement seek
out another citizen to be a witness if
you feel the need to break the window to
get into the car to save the dog
and thirdly screenshot the local
temperature for your own added
protection this could be extremely
helpful to have the outside temperature
temperature documented to determine the
car's inside temperature
again according to the nhspca
temperatures rise exponentially inside a
vehicle and veterinarians across the
country are always trying to save those
victims of unintentional neglect
leaving an animal in a hot car occurs in
every state across this country it can
be prevented if we act now and make a
positive change today please consider
looking out for our animal companions
thanks to all of you for your time and
effort that you've put into this issue
and thank you for listening to me
advocate on behalf of animals across the
country and in the state of new
hampshire
thank you for your testimony
seeing no hands raised the wind is
excused
again there's any members of the public
who are in attendance that we should
testify that have not testified already
please raise your hand
seeing no hands raised at this time we
will close the public hearing
on senate bill 110
mr chair we had eight people signing in
in support of the bill and no one
signing in in opposition
this time
we will be in reach
until
committee
will now open
the public hearing on senate bill 60
and add prohibiting the transport of an
open container of marijuana in a motor
vehicle or ho
rb
senator again
representative peterson
introduced the belt
can you hear me now
can you hear me
oh you can't okay i'm in an auditorium
i'm going to walk outside if you can
bear with me for 30 seconds i'm working
in a school
can you give me 30 seconds to get
outside
i'm picking up the pace thank you for
your patience
[Music]
okay i'm outside i think you'll get
better reception can you hear me
yes we can hear you
awesome thank you
uh let me get to a little table so i'm
not out of breath
i'm the blue collar senator who has to
do work so i've been hanging stage
curtains this morning
okay
sb 60. um
a simple bill really for
uh we passed it bipartisan legislation
you probably can see the count better
than i think it was about 16 to 8 17 to
five or six
um
we're losing ten thousand lives here on
our roads pre-covered uh 1.6 million
arrests per year for driving under the
influence and the evidence prior to cove
had suggested that alcohol is going down
for impairment but
um use of illicit drugs
and marijuana going up so our roads have
become
less safe for people under the influence
the chiefs of police in new hampshire
came to me and said they were having a
problem on the roads
that people were
using gummies and other stuff stuff that
they were medicinally medicating for
and they had them next to them on the
seat and they were having a problem
people handing them off to the other
people in the car saying oh it wasn't
mine i didn't take it it's somebody
else's in the car so they said they were
having problems and that's why we
brought the bill forward
it's a simple idea i sat on the
marijuana commission
four or five years ago i've been very
involved in a lot of the marijuana bills
over the last eight years so i was
always told by all the marijuana
advocates to treat it
the same as alcohol as far as like being
in a car or anything so you can't have
an open bottle we don't want you have an
open container because there's a
temptation so if you do have an unsealed
container we're asking you put it in the
glove box put it under a back seat put
it under the trunk same as you would
have to do if you had an open bottle now
i realize some people have an amendment
today and they're going to say there and
that may be a good amendment it wasn't
really thought of in the senate the idea
and the amendment i believe
is to
for people who have medicinal marijuana
they could have it open but the problem
is medicinal marijuana isn't really
prescribed
accurately by a doctor you get a
prescription but then you're sent to
a medicinal marijuana
place and you get stuff but you don't
know how much you're getting we don't
know dosage don't know amounts i wish
someday when the government gets more
involved that they would regulate it you
can't have
your doctor or physician's assistant
doesn't send you to get medication
and you decide the prescription the
amount the dosage the strength so i
don't see that it should be treated
exactly the same as any other medication
again the idea of the bill was to keep
substances away from the driver we
lowered the penalty to 150
so it wasn't an onerous burden
and the police have said they are not
going to use it to
they're going to try to keep our roads
safer they're not going after people
they're not after anyone on medicinal
marijuana they are not on any purge of
marijuana they again chest are having
problems keeping people from being
impaired while driving and that was the
idea behind the bill
and i'm open to any questions uh some of
the chiefs are coming after me and
they're probably better but i'm okay on
the bill
can you still hear me
thank you
representative
there seems to be a lot of issues about
whether the container
open sealed
whatever
why don't we just ban any marijuana in
the passenger compartment
of a car
well we were trying to make it a less
onerous burden on people who may have
medicinal marijuana if it's sealed in
the container and the police stop you
then you can they'll see it's a sealed
package they'll know you're not using it
just like if you had a bottle any other
get alcohol in the car it's in a sealed
bottle we don't ban it from being in the
car we just pan it from being open
because we don't want people to be
tempted to use it i don't want people to
be tempted to grab a couple gummies and
then be impaired while they're driving
thank you
representative morgan you're recognized
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much senator i
have a question about
um it says marijuana show me have the
same meaning as cannabis type drug
and i looked up rsa 318 b 1 4. and
does it uh does it in fact
doesn't in fact
cover like cannabis you know
cannabis infused gummies that you've uh
referred to several times that sort of
thing it does yes it does it does we
added if you i think you should have the
amended version from the senate uh the
department of health and human services
had us add
um i was using the phraseology too
loosely with marijuana and they wanted
therapeutic cannabis and they had a
coverall that that was legally accepted
in the in the state of new hampshire so
we deferred to them and they put in a
couple phrases so it covered everything
all right thanks
thank you mr chair
representative knight you were
recognized for a question
thank you so much for taking my question
so um
what is the definition of sealed
um so when you go to
you buy your cannabis there is the seal
much like
i haven't seen it i haven't been to the
dispensaries myself yeah there's not
it's a sticker
okay i okay so as long as the sticker
seal is not broken i've been told it's
sort of like a pack of cigarettes or
a carton of stars and there's either an
ill label as long as that hasn't been
broken
the police should be able to see if the
seal is broken or not
follow-up chair
better play please let me remind you if
you ask a question please let the
witness answer the question
okay
follow-up please
iandoora thank you for the question
so
so can i
take stickers in my car and research
can you take a package and reseal them i
think the police will testify as they
have more familiarity with it this
couple the police chiefs are going to
testify after me
they have let indicated to me that you
could tell it wasn't just like you'd
open and close the sticker they were i
have been informed that once the seal is
broken it would be evident that the seal
was broken so you could ask chief zigori
and there's a couple of the chiefs if in
fact that's the case
i just want to remind the members of the
committee that we as members are going
to be
witnesses
anyways
representative newman you're recognized
for a question
i don't uh have a question i just did
not hear what you said uh we should be
aware of it was not didn't come through
clearly
i apologize again i'm sorry i usually
would zoom this i just
i had to work today um so i'm under a
big tent here at in tewkesbury high
school um so i i think we were talking
about me and the other representative
she was asking about the seal i the
police will come after me and they can
testify they have told me that it is
evident when the seal is broken much
like a pack of cigarettes are much like
a cigar carton some of them have plastic
seals some of them have maybe there are
more seals than i'm aware of but they
can testify to what they're finding out
there again i haven't physically seen
the sealed container but i've been told
it's much like a pack of cigarettes when
you open it you can tell it's open
representative newman you have a
follow-up question
yeah well it's a statement i want to
apologize to the senator that i did not
correctly address the chair and i was
talking to the senator but i mean to the
chair and i appreciate that additional
information
no no i'm i'm probably the one
i want to apologize to the committee
that i'm i'm not my suit and tie dressed
up and rearing and ready to go but again
um the idea is that we keep the
container or keep any marijuana a
temptation away from the driver and you
don't want him to be able to hand it to
the passenger next to him because
it would be much like if he had no my
friends like to drive and drink in high
school i always told him it was a bad
idea but they say oh you can just pass
it to the guy in the next seat and we
don't want you passing anything to the
guy in the next seat we just don't want
an open temptation there the police have
said they're having problems on our
roads that's why we brought the bill
forward
thank you
representative conley you're recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking the question
uh as
as i suspect you know new hampshire
hasn't carefully negotiated the
criminalization statute
yup
i've lost you i'm sorry go can you
repeat that
my question is does this
do you are you concerned that this bill
does not order with the careful needed
criminalization statute around cannabis
which i
we had um
senate our senate attorney examined it
the police the police had their lawyers
look over the bill and i have been told
that everything conforms to new
hampshire state laws
thank you
i appreciate that i guess my question is
this goes well beyond what is
contemplated in the decriminalization
statute particularly the suspension of a
license i guess i'm wondering
uh
how do these statutes coexist could
someone be charged under both
uh if this law is passed
so chief chigory and the other police
chiefs have assured me senator french
has the same concern
was very concerned that there was a
higher fine we lowered it actually lower
than i believe massachusetts maine and
vermont
um
and he was afraid that people are going
to
be overly zealous in enforcing this the
chiefs will come on later and
they confirm to senator french that this
will be used
at the beginning it's really just going
to be used as as an option they're going
to tell you the first time
you know you have an open container
please don't do that anymore as it
mounts up time after time and they have
a record that you're breaking the law
you'll go after the 150 then if you're a
repeat offender
and they they have reason to believe
that you're using the stuff then then
they're going to be more zealous in
their advocacy of the bill
okay thank you
representative
thank you for taking my question
one of the things i'm i'm kind of
curious about it are the the
implications of having to store
um
uh you know what could be medicine in a
trunk in a hot trunk you know possibly
uh for hours uh i know that when people
buy alcohol at the at the state store
if we uh if we insisted everybody put it
uh in there
in their trunk
we'd probably be stopping 95 percent of
the cars that leave
our new hampshire state liquor stores
so
i'm i'm curious
why
the the different standard for for
marijuana that could actually
um
uh let's jeopardize the efficacy of
what's medicine uh for some people uh if
it if it actually gets damaged in a
trunk um when we don't require the same
thing for for alcohol
so the idea is to keep the roads safe so
if you have so you're not going to
uh let's say you're asking me
uh
you can oh most must most of it you
could just put in glove compartment you
could put it under your back seat it's
stupid you don't have to put it in the
trunk the idea is to keep it there's a
idea and law called um
it's an arms reach doctrine you want to
keep weapons you want to keep drugs you
want to keep everything as far away from
the driver as possible that's sort of
where we're mirroring that if you put it
under the back seat that would be fine
as far as possible from the driver if
you put it in either of the glove most
cars have two glove compartments put it
in the car some type of compartment
just don't have it sitting out next to
you open
just again treating is the same as
alcohol saying don't have something that
can
uh impair your driving next to you it's
very hard to prosecute
people on thc as opposed to alcohol the
tests are much harder to prove
and so again we the idea here is to keep
the roads as safe as possible
thank you
i think the chiefs are probably
probably better than me at this but
we'll see how they are after
hi representative how you doing today
section four i have a problem
okay i don't have the bill in front of
me i'm sorry it's back on the stage but
go ahead i've read it many times
a taxi or a limousine in this smoking
water
should there be a petition between them
and the driver
that that's a good observation um
i like that officer yes the chief said
i'll defer to their judgment on that
they'll have a minute or two to think
about their answer so why don't we defer
that one to the chiefs
thank you sorry it was under these
conditions have a great day guys
the channel recognizes chief andrew
siguri
how about now can you hear me okay
um
thank you for uh taking my
my call into this meeting thank you for
the meeting
members of the committee and the
chairman abbas
um this is designed to mirror
transporting alcohol in a vehicle um
it's
it's similar to the same requirements in
many other states vermont
massachusetts bordering us which many of
our residents come from
our visitors come from and our residents
visit
illinois delaware colorado california
alaska has it in anchorage
new york just passed spanning its use in
vehicles
nevada
oklahoma oregon from i said vermont and
washington very very similar laws
i want to emphasize this isn't about
legalization decriminalization or
anything this is about public safety
with vehicles on public ways
right now as uh
representative connolly pointed out we
have
decriminalization but there's a kind of
a
there's a miss in there there's a
there's an issue in there
um and i just ran into this not too long
ago
um
the decrim law treats somebody driving
down the road the same as somebody on
the sidewalk using it
and i think there's quite a difference
between somebody driving down the road
with marijuana
and somebody on the sidewalk using it
what can happen is if you get somebody
between the age of 16 and 18
they potentially face uh a misdemeanor
for transporting drugs
under uh
265 a 43
and that's a mandatory loss license for
60 days
and it's a higher fine this treats
everybody that's doing this dangerous
thing
transporting potentially using it while
they're driving
as if
the same
uh one of the things that i was looking
at
recently was a colorado department of
health and human services they did
they do a compendium of the studies and
what they're experiencing out there
what um they're seeing through the
studies
uh and what happens first off they said
that drivers should wait six hours after
use some marijuana at least
and they're also saying it could be
longer if they're using edibles
they're finding there's a strong
evidence of studies showing that edibles
can take up to four hours to
the thc to enter the bloodstream and
impact
a person's ability after they ingest it
smoking can take as few as 10 minutes
and i'd point out therapeutic cannabis
impairs drivers just as any other
marijuana there's no difference in how
it affect how the impairment that can
come from
marijuana
we're seeing more and more drivers
impaired with it we're dealing with it
on the streets um
again it's it's not targeted at any
group this is
we believe all unsealed containers
should be out of reach of the driver
uh if there's an issue that like uh
representative harriet garth wright
brought up and apologize if i
mispronounced the name
that could be addressed to rulemaking
with health and human services is what
the atcs need to do
as far as sealing
but if it can't be sealed it really
shouldn't be within reach of the driver
while it's on a public way
in a in a private way it doesn't count
this law doesn't apply
uh this is this is essentially treating
alcohol like marijuana the same as the
law uh and i used as a model when i was
framing this uh the current open contain
a lot for alcoholic beverages
one of the things that's happening
legislatively this session and i don't
know if some of you may or may not be
aware of this because it has gone
through other committees there's more
atc's opening alternative treatment
centers there's one opening keene
there's one opening in chichester people
aren't having to drive long distances
now to get their
[Music]
therapeutic cannabis
so it they shouldn't have to have a long
period to get home after they get it
um so there shouldn't be a need and if
there is a sudden urge that they need to
use it it's critical
they can pull into a private place and
do it or they can wait till they get
home the problem the problem with
marijuana unlike alcohol alcohol
typically about 45 minutes after you
ingest alcohol all of it is in your
system elevates and you're being able to
be tested and we have standard numbers
for that problem with marijuana is when
people ingest it it could hit them later
for example i guess mentioned the
edibles can take four hours to impact
somebody's ability to drive they could
take it go off driving thinking they're
fine and it shows up later
part of the problem with therapeutic 2
is there's really no way to check
cards
so if we're just exempt therapeutic
patients we have no way of knowing who
has a card who doesn't have a card it's
all privileged no and it's not an issue
i'm not raising that issue but i'm
saying there's no way for an officer on
the street to verify that easily if they
don't have the card or if they're from
out of state
um i think
this is about fundamentally it's about
public safety and safety on the roads
not about use
no uh into one of the points that was
raised was um
on the penalties how how obtainer of
alcohol is typically done
typically now the there is no mandate
that a license gets suspended with open
containers of alcohol in fact i can't
think of a time
with an open container of alcohol that
we've seen somebody
uh that that comes to my mind anyways
i've done this 33 years this law wasn't
in place all 33 years
but uh
it is in an egregious case a judge could
say hey you're going to lose your
license for 30 days that was outrageous
for you to do what you did and
endangered the public
i haven't seen it but it gives the judge
that opportunity it's not the police
that are that can take the license it's
up to a judge gives them that discretion
as opposed to 265 843 which gives no
discretion
uh it's you shall lose your license
uh if you run into if i just ran into
somebody not too long ago 17
and she fell into that it's an a
misdemeanor
and you shall lose your license and it's
it's more punitive this kind of pulls a
penalty back
makes it a violation
and it
and it makes it up to the judge if the
judge feels it's an egregious case that
needs to send a message to that
particular person because of their
history
they could the judge could impose it
i've never seen it happen
but it it gives that ability if somebody
were really endangering the public
through their conduct um
there was a question also about a
barrier with
i i don't know about that i mean it's
according to what the colorado
department health and human services
their study there's no evidence of
second-hand smoke
impairs
other people in the vehicle
and and something like a limo or
something it i
unless it's like you know the proverbial
you know vehicle from cheech and chong
that was
had smoke rolling out the windows i
don't see how somebody could uh
ingest enough to impact the you know if
the passenger is using it in the back
seat and as in a taxi that the driver
would be impaired but again if it's a
taxi that'd be up to the the actually
the company policy really i would think
uh but i think we have to because
recognize
what i've seen for especially with the
edibles like the gummies and the the
sour worms i've seen they're in sealed
package just like you get gummies in the
you know candy so if that were ripped
open
that's the way i've seen them anyways uh
that we've
collected them from other places so that
to me
would be uh pretty obvious and this
really like i said because of the new
places opening the distance between them
is much shorter than it was when this
started with therapeutic there's really
no reason that somebody should go hours
if they really have to have it on such a
frequent basis
that
that they couldn't accommodate that
without driving
thank you i'll take your questions
thank you chief for your testimony the
chair
has a question
of the witness and i want to thank you
in advance for taking my question
uh for someone who's driving a vehicle
that doesn't have a trunk
let's just say at the
ford 150
where in that vehicle would you
suggest is the least accessible to the
driver
thank you this is modeled right after
the alcohol container law which has the
same provision it says has to be as far
as possible away from
from the driver so if you have a pickup
i have a f350 single cab no
spare seat or anything
i i can put stuff behind my seat and
it's out of my reach i couldn't i'd have
in order for me to grab like a bottle or
something behind my seat i'd have to
stop and pull over grab it or you could
put it away as far as you can away from
the driver within their confines that
vehicle uh nobody's asking people you
have to get a vehicle with a trunk but
it has to be as far away as possible
and i realize there's fewer fewer and
fewer sedans are being made more suvs
you put it in the back where you put
your groceries and stuff
and to raise there was a question about
conditioning well that would be
conditioned too
but
is
here
we have problems here in that last uh
last question
so the follow-up question is
i read it to say which is the least
accessible to the driver and i interpret
that
to apply to just a single location
in the vehicle
so i'm what i'm what i'm asking
is
maybe more than one location that may
not be accessible to the driver
but i'm i'm reading that that the it has
to be stored
where that is least accessible to the
driver so
i'm just asking how is that determined
i understand it may not may not be
within the reach of the driver
i hear what you're saying because it
could be two places inaccessible one
more
i think
uh
i think in the case of like i think with
my pickup where it's least accessible
behind the front behind the seat
obviously is least accessible to me
uh
i i think
i understand the question i think when
you
that we've been applying this for
alcohol for quite a while and i don't
think that's ever come up as i think
it's always been
we're trying to keep it away from the
front seat with the driver you know what
i mean where they can easily access it
and use it as they're driving
uh that's
there may be some language but then this
is again i modeled it after the alcohol
one to keep it
along the same
experience line for police and the
public for alcohol
and it's along the lines of what other
states have required
in two adjoining states
thank you for taking my question um
one of the things that you testified to
is that edibles can take
up to four hours to take effect
so
um
one of the things that made me wonder is
whether whether edibles should actually
be exempt
because even if a person had an open
container sitting next to them
um and had just had one five minutes
before
they wouldn't necessarily feel the
effects for for quite a while um
so
i guess my my question is is there seems
to be
well there are there are differences in
the way that alcohol work versus the way
that some of the cannabis products work
that don't seem to be accounted for in
this bill
and i guess my question is is do you
think we need to do a better job of
accounting for those variations
no i don't think so because i think they
both impair drivers
um part of the issue would be
you don't know when when i stop somebody
i don't know when they've had alcohol i
don't know when they've had that
marijuana
if they have edibles
a common thing that happens
somebody will go to a party say with it
with a bunch of beer or a bottle they'll
take bottles with them
they're not they may not leave them well
same thing with edibles if you have a
bag of edibles you took to you know i've
i've heard of dorm parties where they
bring them
you know if you have a bag of edibles
and now you're not going to just leave
them you're going to take your the
remaining home with you you may have had
them earlier
we have no idea when somebody actually
took it when we stopped somebody
that you your
edibles still impair people
and it can take up to four hours it
depends on how it is what kind
depends on what you've eaten
your experience with it
unlike
unlike alcohol
marijuana thc thc is the active part
that impairs your ability to drive
thc doesn't necessarily follow along a
straight path like alcohol alcohol 45
minutes it's typically in your system
depending upon how much you had to eat
and how much you drank how fast and it
dissipates from your body at a steady
rate 0.015
per hour
marijuana doesn't work that way it's fat
soluble it takes longer
to dissipate depending upon your
your body makeup how much you have how
frequently you have it because it
doesn't necessarily all dissipate at
once
so i i don't this is all about public
safety and driving down the road i don't
think you need to make a differentiation
because they both impair you
they both
cause problems for drivers and you don't
know when they took it
representative news you recognized for a
follow-up question
um
one thing i'm i'm also wondering about
are the circumstances for potential
stops in this area
so for this law to be enforced or or in
circumstances where you think this law
would be enforced what are the most
likely circumstances
that would uh involve the officer making
this type of a stop
uh well it could be any number of
reasons
typically
um
the one in my particular case it's an
open case i'm kind of shouldn't probably
shouldn't talk a whole lot about it but
this person blew a stop sign and pulled
into my lane of travel
uh and i stopped this person for a stop
sign violation
and driving on the wrong side of the
road afterwards um
so it's it's a matter
i don't see that you could
you know with with vape cartridges for
example you you can't you can't tell
what's in them so even if you saw smoke
you wouldn't know what somebody's
smoking you so you couldn't necessarily
stop for that um
it's it'd be in most of this mostly you
if it was a gummy you couldn't tell if
it's a gummy or not it would be
something you stop them for another
reason
typically or erratic operation they're
driving erratically
thank you i'm senator pantalas you're
recognized
oh okay
yes
it
is not to do with uh
accidents and what not occur
and they cannot be charged with drunken
driving because it was not there but
they were very impaired
would just serve as evidence
so
part of what happened with the alcohol
and how the open container came to be is
we had people drinking and driving
and
part of the problem is you know like i
said it takes 45 minutes well you could
stop somebody right after they drank
and they're passing the test i'd have no
problem cause to arrest them because
they passed sobriety tests they could go
down the roads to continue driving and
then it could by that time they could be
impaired to a degree where it's
dangerous
a similar thing could happen with
marijuana they could use marijuana it
may not be affecting them at the time
you stopped them because they just used
it
so now i have no problem cause to arrest
them i
you know i let them drive off and then
they could be impaired down the road
because that's when the effects will
will overcome them their ability to
safely drive a vehicle
so this is this again it's it's a it's a
tool to help make sure we're safer on
the roads
it's not something it's very hard to get
people with with with marijuana they
don't test the same as far as seeing
them
they manifest how they act
uh
they do
there is no per se or prima facie limit
so even if we get a test back saying
they have 10 nanograms
per milliliter in blood we don't know
we can't necessarily say that's that's
enough
but that's different that's a different
topic i guess i'm kind of shifting gears
it is tough this is just another tool to
help us deal with people who decide to
use it while driving it may deter some
people from having it with them where
they could use it while driving it's
it's that's what it's about it's trying
to keep the public safe it's not about
criminalizing marijuana it's not about
punishing therapeutic patients it's
it's about
safety on the roads and it and i don't
and to the decrim law treats people
driving the same as somebody sitting on
a park bench using it which i think
there's a difference
thank you
representative newman you're recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you chief
for taking the question
my question has to do with the last part
of paragraph roman numeral one and it
says essentially that if if a vehicle
has a trunk you shall transport um open
uh containers in that trunk
is that is that a correct interpretation
because people keep talking about having
it in the passenger compartment
that is correct
if you have a trunk if you have an old
container of alcohol you have to put it
in there if you do not have a trunk then
you have to put it in a place that's rel
inaccessible to the driver as best you
can
i mean i don't know of anybody
you know
and it's to treat it the same it should
be in the trunk
so it's not in accessible to the driver
i don't think i i've never known anybody
to sit there and say oh well it was
they put it in the you know with an suv
for example while they put it in the
left rear which is closer than the right
rear to the driver i've never heard
anybody charged like that because they
made an effort you know what i mean i
think
representative newman you recognized
follow-up question just to understand
what the response was there it doesn't
say you should keep it in the trunk the
law says
you shall keep it in the trunk is that a
problem
i don't believe so i think if if you
have a trunk you shall put it in the
trunk if you don't have a trunk
then you have to go the other way
thank you
if the motor vehicle or hiv does not
have a trunk such container shall be
stored and transported in that
compartment or area which is least
accessible so it's a compartment too
it's an area it's not necessarily a uh
a defined the furthest point it's an
area compartment
again this is right after the alcohol
law this is how we
deal with the open containers of alcohol
now so i don't see a big
uh
learning curve for law enforcement
because we're used to applying this in
alcohol cases
uh and i don't see it uh it being a
major impediment
shouldn't be a major impediment for the
for the motor in public because it is
the same as alcohol they have to do now
with alcohol
thank you
representative klein knight you're
recognized
thank you chair um
thank you uh
chief for taking my question
in your opinion what do you think is
worse oxycodone alcohol or marijuana
all three
well uh if
any one of them is bad free for use on
the impaired drivers which is what this
is about in public safety they each have
different uh impacts on people and
um
probably oxy is the worst but in
different ways and
uh that's uh
follow-up term
you're recognized for a follow-up
question
why
isn't anybody making laws about
medication like oxycodone men in
comparison
good question
uh
i'm trying to
one piece at a time making our way there
i guess
i think
the diff there's a difference though i
mean
there is a law on transporting drugs for
oxycodone
that would be 265 843
so if somebody is carrying it and
they're not supposed to have it
there's a
a penalty
uh that mandates a loss of license
so it's it's actually more severe
in that sense
follow-up
and up to two years for loss of license
limiting members did
a few questions
so
we've got a lot of witnesses um
seeing no uh for the hands raised
uh i'm gonna make the appointments for
his testimony
thank you
cheerio
recognizes represent representative
jerry canard
thank you very much representative abbas
uh for the record i'm representative
jerry kanerk from carroll county
district
oh by the way can you hear me okay
yeah
okay fine and i also serve as the chair
of the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board
the tcmob of therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board is composed of
the chief medical officer of dhhs
a qualifying patient representative a
clinical representative from an atc and
10 medical providers from various fields
we're charged with the task of advising
the therapeutic cannabis program on
medical issues including qualifying
conditions
now today i'm not here to report a
recommendation of the tcmob as we did
not review this specific bill
but i am presenting how we view the use
of therapeutic cannabis
i am here to urge exemption of
therapeutic cannabis patients and
caregivers from this bill
using therapeutic cannabis is simply not
the same as alcohol this comparison of
cannabis and alcohol has been made many
times but i'd like to note that we do
not have a therapeutic alcohol program
in this state
the goal of using cannabis in the
therapeutic setting
is different from the goal and
recreational use of cannabis
in recreational use
the point is to get high
therapeutic cannabis is not used to get
high
but instead to treat a condition
doses in therapeutic cannabis are
titrated using the rubric
low and slow
you start with a low dose
and you very slowly build to achieve the
therapeutic effect
while minimizing the side effect of
getting high
in therapeutic cannabis getting high
is a negative side effect
it is not
the desired effect
in the therapeutic cannabis program
patients are certified as having a
qualifying condition for which
therapeutic cannabis is approved
they then possess and use the cannabis
as though it were a regular medication
contrary to what senator gannon earlier
stated the cannabis obtained in an atc
comes in a clearly labeled container
which states precisely the content of
the cannabinoids determined by analysis
of that specific batch of cannabis
the dose is not
unknown to the patient they know
precisely what they're taking
the patient may use cannabis regularly
or they may just use it when their
symptoms flare
comments are made about
being on the road from picking up their
cannabis that's not likely that's not
likely the time when they're going to
unseal it when traveling
for example to go visit a friend
to go out to dinner to go anywhere they
may need to take their therapeutic
cannabis with them
because they may take it again regularly
or may have a flare of a symptom at a
time they don't expect it
and it is highly likely that when
traveling and taking their therapeutic
cannabis from home that they probably
have already unsealed the container of
cannabis
which they legally obtained at the atc
they would have already opened it to use
at home
just like if i have a prescription for
medication in my
uh
closet it's not likely that it would not
have ever been opened because i would be
using it
now i really need to comment on a few
earlier statements there was a comment
made about sharing therapeutic cannabis
just handing a gummy to your passenger
it is already illegal for a therapeutic
cannabis patient to divert their
therapeutic cannabis to another
subject to criminal penalties and
resulting in loss of certification
regarding the officer not being able to
check cards
under rsa 126 x
3 6
a qualifying patient or designated
caregiver
who is found to be in possession of
cannabis
outside of his or home her home
and is not in possession of his or her
registry identification card may be
subject to a fine of 100
regarding that issue about being in the
trunk that representative muse asked
high heat is likely to adversely affect
the therapeutic cannabis just as it does
other medications
comet was just made about other
medicines and referred to
um
controlled substances being transported
that's controlled substances of people
who are not supposed to have them
my understanding is that rsa 318 b14
which previously required controlled
drugs to be in their original container
was repealed in 2011.
this bill would impose an even more
stringent burden on therapeutic cannabis
patients than the original repealed
318b14
as it requires not only the original
candidater but an unbroken original seal
therapeutic cannabis is the equivalent
of a prescribed medication
it is not the same as an open can of
beer
if the patient is not actively using
their therapeutic cannabis in the
vehicle
and they say they just have it in a
backpack they just threw in their back
seaters they're going to visit a friend
they should not be penalized
so i urge you to amend this bill
to create an exemption for a registered
therapeutic cannabis program patients
and
caregivers both from this law i also do
have a concern
that on section 4 of sb 60 lines 19 to
there is an exemption for a driver
transporting a person for hire
but should this amendment also exempt a
friend who gives a ride to a therapeutic
cannabis patient who just happens to
have his therapeutic cannabis with him
perhaps in his pocket so that he just so
that he does not forget to take it with
him when he reaches his destination
he may be dropped off he hops out and he
says oh my gosh i left my cannabis in
the guy's trunk
well under this bill with that driver
who's not for hire be held responsible
for the passengers behavior they may not
even be aware that this person has it
so
we keep talking about people using it
it's
if you're a therapeutic cannabis patient
it's already illegal to use it it's
already illegal to share it
i do agree that there are difficulties
in determining impairment with thc that
is a problem but this bill
doesn't really solve that problem it
just places an undue burden on
therapeutic cannabis patients holding to
a higher standard that we do for
narcotics
somewhat in reference to what
representative
klein knight just said and it simply is
something that should have an exemption
for therapeutic cannabis patients
caregiver and caregivers both thank you
and i'll be glad to take any questions
representative uses your hand
actually my i do not have a question
see no hands raised i want to thank the
representative for this testimony
you're welcome
i want to apologize i did not announce
the beginning of the new public hearing
[Music]
this time the chair recognizes just
selena josephine
hello uh can you hear me
good morning members of the committee
thank you for hearing my testimony
my name is helena josephson and i live
in canaan new hampshire and i'm speaking
in opposition to sb60
this bill unfairly targets people like
me a disabled granite stater who legally
uses therapeutic cannabis to treat my
medical conditions
by treating therapeutic cannabis like
alcohol rather than like other
prescription medications we're further
stigmatizing patients whose medicine
happens to be cannabis
other prescription medications can be
within reach of a driver why single out
this one it's a medicine but we aren't
doing this for other medicines
i'd like to eliminate stigma around
therapeutic cannabis and i'm not sure
that this does that
intoxicated driving is a top health and
safety concern and other medications
cause impairment dui laws applies to
substances beyond alcohol the term open
container refers to a substance that
might be consumed while driving i heard
testimony referring to temptation and
frankly i'm appalled how does my
medication tempt my driver
i keep my medication in my purse which
is an extension of my person if a friend
or relative is giving me a ride my purse
stays on my lap the driver can reach my
purse would this law mean that the
driver might be liable for what's in my
purse
i also heard testimony suggesting that
the open container helps police know to
check a driver for cannabis related
impairment
i carry my patient card in my purse and
i'd happily present it
but i would never drive while under the
influence of my medication i just that's
a choice that i make because
i don't need this law to prevent me from
driving while impaired
i also heard testimony suggesting that a
patient quote shouldn't need to carry an
open package of gummy medicine
how is it anyone's business how and when
i take my medication as long as i'm not
driving while impaired
it doesn't sound like the writers of
this bill understand therapeutic
cannabis and it also sounds like the
purpose of this bill
is really not about driver safety but
really to give police more reason to
check drivers
thank you for hearing my testimony
this morning
getting your hands raised
the witness is excused
chair now recognizes jim
our wiki
just a reminder
your pessimism for two minutes
thank you for hearing me today can you
hear me okay
my name is jim kawaki i reside in san
bernardin new hampshire
i actually hold the first federal hemp
license since hemp was legal through the
farm bill in 2018
now that license i hold also means
something to new hampshire
it means new hampshire has the first
federal license for hemp legalization
here in new hampshire
we have up to 10 farms now
that is it
so we have a history here for a plant
that has been
prohibited for so many years
and we have finally legalized it i
worked with the house and the body
on the legalization
the implementation
um we are allowed to sell products
that look like marijuana but they are
not
so this bill has serious implications
for people who purchase
hemp and cbd products
because now it leaves a whole another
area
for law enforcement
to look into and if someone is
walking up a hiking trail
pulled over on their bicycle a nice pawn
having a break smoking
some hemp
and they're harassed for that and we
have legalized that in this state
uh we're going to follow that same
category with the marijuana that they're
trying to do now
honestly i have hemp accessible in my
vehicle all the time
it helps me a lot with my inflammation
and if i have a flare-up and i'm driving
for a long distance i can use my hemp
smoke it it's gonna smell like marijuana
but it is federally legal and it helps
my inflammation and more likely than not
if a cop law enforcement officer smells
that
um we're gonna have a conversation and
and once again it's the stigma again and
i just see this as a very bad bill
and from a farmer's standpoint um with
the history new hampshire has it would
be a shame to say that we were the first
federally licensed state
and all of our farmers are closing down
because law enforcement is
going to
put such stringent policies against the
plant cannabis which is an herb not
necessarily a drug so fire
i am complete
any questions
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh so you mentioned
hemp and you mentioned c
cpd
and my understanding is the cpd does not
have the chemical necessary to
impair a person
um is it the same thing for hemp does it
not have tcp in it
that is correct um our hemp is grown we
have a
person who comes from a dea lab to our
farm actually pulls a sample brings it
back to their lab and tests it and sends
us as well as the fbi in the usda a
certificate of analysis of the hemp we
have grown
to prove that it is legal to have in new
hampshire and sell and i personally hand
delivered a copy of my certificate
analysis to our police chief because we
have a very good
relationship very open
thank you
you're welcome
seeing no further hands raised the
witnesses excuse i want to thank you for
your testimony
thank you
the chair now recognizes michael holt
just a reminder of your testimonies in
two minutes
thank you very much my name is michael
holt i'm the administrator of the
state's therapeutic cannabis program the
department doesn't take a position on
this bill my testimony is informational
including a request for an amendment
as we know senate bill 60 would create
in new hampshire an open container law
for cannabis
first i want to thank senator gannon for
working with the department on an
amendment to this bill in the senate
that clarified that this legislation was
not intended to specifically target
therapeutic cannabis patients that
amendment fixed the statutory reference
to the definition of cannabis from a
citation in the therapeutic cannabis law
to the citation and the controlled drug
act so thank you senator gannon
the department requests your
consideration of an additional amendment
to this bill that affords further
protection to therapeutic cannabis
patients
as written this bill would apply the
proposed open container prohibitions and
penalties to every person including
those qualifying patients and designated
caregivers who are registered with the
state's therapeutic cannabis program and
who can legally possess therapeutic
cannabis as though it were any other
regular medication
there is no open container law for
prescription medications in new
hampshire the public is permitted to
possess in their vehicle or anywhere
their unsealed prescription containers
without penalty in fact in 2010 the new
hampshire legislature via this committee
repealed the law that required
prescribed controlled medication to be
maintained in its original container
that bill was house bill 1667
in new hampshire therapeutic cannabis
for registered patients is the effective
equivalent of prescribed medication
should not be considered the equivalent
of an open can of beer or bottle of
liquor
this requested amendment would protect
the more than 11 000 qualifying patients
registered with the therapeutic cannabis
program from a violation a fine and a
60-day or one-year licensed suspension
for possessing their therapeutic
cannabis the same way as they are
allowed by state law to handle any of
their other medications
the department asks for your
consideration of amendment number
1161 which would exempt tcp patients and
caregivers from this proposed open
container law for cannabis
i want to thank representative welch for
agreeing to present that amendment to
this committee
if i may i'd like to provide one more
piece of information about current and
long-standing department practice
every patient
the whole your time is expired
strength
representative newman
aaron thanks for the witness to taking
the question
muted
thank you mr chair and the witness
witness for taking the question should
cbd also be included in that type of
amendment or do you think that
that the law um
as written covers that that you wouldn't
be prosecuted
representative thank you for the
question you're going in and out in
terms of muting um
my uh the statutory change the
definition of cannabis that happened in
the senate um now sites to the
definition of cannabis in the controlled
drug act that definition does not
exclude
industrial hemp
like other definitions of cannabis
throughout state law
so
uh thinking on the fly here um
this uh based on the testimony we heard
from um mr kawaki um then a further
amendment may be justified to exclude
hemp products from this but again that's
this is an answer on the fly and uh and
the department doesn't have a position
particularly on the treatment of hemp um
separate from that
of therapeutic cannabis patients
representative newman you recognize for
a follow-up
thank you and and just for further
clarification cbd the medication that
people take that does not make them
impaired
is that affected by this law if you had
an open container of that type of
medication
would you be subject to this open
container law
cbd
that's a that is that is a good question
therapeutic cannabis patients have
access through the licensed alternative
treatment centers in the state to a
variety of cannabis products some of
them are thc rich and some of them are
cbd rich
the point of this requested amendment
would would be to exempt the population
of therapeutic cannabis patients and
their caregivers from this open
container provision
that
the complicating factor that you raise
representative newman is that cbd
is available
retail
to anyone in the public it is available
anywhere gas stations
health food stores etc etc cbd is
cannabis under the uh controlled drug um
act in new hampshire um and so what this
sugg that suggests that somebody who is
possessing an open container of a
non-intoxicating substance like cbd
would be impacted negatively by this
this bill as well
again my testimony is in
is requesting an amendment for the
therapeutic cannabis population and not
the
new hampshire citizenry at large
thank you very much
representatives you're recognized
thank you for taking my question my
question is about the amendment itself
well it sounds like you and
representative welch had actually
drafted an amendment um which which i do
not have uh is that amendment uh in the
works uh in terms of sending it to
members of the committee so we can take
a look at it
is that a question to the chair
that's a question for whoever wants to
answer it
i haven't i have not seen any
one so exist i will
it's been asked to be sent out it will
be resent
okay thank you
thank you mr chair uh i um as always uh
my opinions are my own not those
supernh law or uh unh itself um i'll be
uh as brief as i can again
uncharacteristically but i think this uh
this statute uh this proposal needs a
good bit of drafting work uh partly
because of the therapeutic cannabis
issues partly because what it partly
because of the 60-day license loss which
will cause people to lose their job
uh even though there's only 150 fine
60-day license loss has a heavy impact
on people who depend uh particularly in
the north country on their car to get to
places so
i have problems with that uh one of my
biggest drafting problems is the
language
least accessible to the driver
you know it doesn't say inaccessible to
the driver least accessible means you
got to find the place in your car where
it's least accessible
um does that mean somebody who's got a
pickup the least accessible place in a
pickup that
doesn't have a trunk is in the bed of
the pickup
i don't think that's what this is
intended but it's a very broad
language uh least accessible as opposed
to
inaccessible and i i think that needs
work i think the definition of sealed
needs work
um you know i think sealed suggests this
is really targeted at therapeutic
marijuana people
uh those who have marijuana in the car
uh that they've acquired at a dispensary
of some sort
um what about uh people who are
possessing what
more formally is known as marijuana
cigarettes cigarettes what is fondly
known as joints
you know
they never were sealed
um you know it's uh
i think while in theory well-intentioned
the the real problem here is that the
proposal
seeks to do indirectly
what needs to what is you know directly
already prohibited that is you can't
drive while under the influence of
marijuana the example chief sugary gave
of somebody running a red light pulling
into the wrong lane
they're
going to be at able to char if they test
that person for marijuana and find
marijuana in their system
they're going to be able to charge that
person because there's there's uh bad
driving that's the key to that kind of
charge so i think this is a over
criminalization the statute the proposal
needs
mr accept my apology your
time's expired you go over by 24 seconds
uh
but we do the time constraints we do
have to
limit testimony
this time the chair recognizes heather
heather brown
uh yes thank you so much for sitting
here and going through all of this today
i truly appreciate it
my name is heather marie brown i am a
therapeutic cannabis patient in the
state of new hampshire but i am also the
co-chair of the new hampshire
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board i hold my seat as the patient
representative and on behalf of the 11
000 plus patients in the state of new
hampshire we are opposed to this bill
this bill has been
developed and created with the intent
of
going after therapeutic cannabis
patients that is all this bill does this
is a very poorly written bill and it
will cause detrimental harm to the
patient community
when i go to a dispensary and i pick up
my medication i go home
and if i have to leave my home i don't
necessarily take my entire bottle with
me i will separate what it is i will
need for the time period i am around my
house put it in another container and
that is what i carry on me
now this bill suggests that i would not
be able to do that even as a patient
even as a passenger in a vehicle
so if my mother
is driving me someplace and i have
therapeutic cannabis in a container that
does not have the safety seal on it that
has been unbroken
then my mother could potentially be
arrested
for that
i think this bill is developed to create
discrimination and division
and i think that a better way to go
about it would have been using it in a
more
manner towards recreational usage versus
the language that's in this bill
it's just a direct attack against
patients and this bill is going to
undermine not only a patient but in some
ways that they're
ms brown i want to thank you for your
testimony the two minutes has expired
so i do have to suspend the testimony
i want to thank you in advance for
testifying
we are running a little behind schedule
that's no surprise the criminal justice
public safety let me just let everyone
know in the members of the public
i'm going to put the hearing on senate
bill 60 in a brief recess
so i can open the public hearing on
senate bill
i do know the prime sponsor is
independence that wishes to
reduce the bill it does have a limited
time schedule so out of respect for uh
the senator
i'm gonna just open the public hearing
on 92
simply to allow that bill to be
introduced and for the response to
testify
then we will then
go into recess and then open and reopen
the public hearing
on sentinel 60.
this time the
public hearing on senate bill 60 is in
recess
at this time
the public hearing on senate bill 92
is open
the chair recognizes senator bradley
good morning can you hear me
yes and thank you very much for the
consideration
of being able to uh testify before your
other hearing is concluded
um i'm pleased to be here
supporting um senate bill 92 which
passed the senate
um on a bipartisan vote i believe of
1727.
there will be a lot of um
you know folks that want to test
for supporting this bill
so let me just say what the bill
seeks to do
it makes
surgical changes
to the bail reform statute that was
passed several years ago it does not
undermine the bail reform statute it
does not
um
make it more difficult for people of
modest means to be able to
obtain bail which was the
premise for efforts a couple of years
ago what it does do on the other hand
is protect victims and protect future
victims from violent behavior
so
let me just go through the four sections
of the bill
the first section dealing with criminal
mischief
we
in the legislature
had dropped the penalty
of um to a violation for any defacing of
public property
the compromise that the senate reached
in going to a class a misdemeanor is if
damage exceeds a thousand dollars or
more that seems to make sense um to try
to prevent
defacing of public property
the second section of the bill which
starts on line seven
is one of the changes to bail reform
and what the the nuts and bolts of it
really is on the second page of the bill
where it lists a number of crimes that
are violent in nature homicide first
degree assault second-degree assault
domestic violence aggravated felonious
sexual assault felonious sexual assault
kidnapping stalking
trafficking
child sexual abuse images
computer pornography and felonious use
of a firearm and designates those
violent crimes that somebody may have
been charged with
as requiring that person seeking bail
to
go before a judge
in order to obtain bail within 72 hours
of the time of that person's arrest it
doesn't end the opportunity for bail it
just makes certain
that people who have
allegedly committed violent crimes are
not released into the public without
having gone before a judge
and so in my view and in the view of the
senate it does not undermine
the bail reform effort that we undertook
a few years ago but it again as i said
before protects
victims in particular of those i think
it's nine or ten different crimes that i
have cited
that is at the top of page two of the
bill
the third
provision of the bill is to change
um from
five years to three years
the number of times that you could have
three or more
um failures to appear
and then if that were to happen a person
could be held in pre-trial detention and
so that's
uh page two and page three
of the bill and i given the testimony i
think you will hear
from
various law enforcement personnel who
are going to testify today
there as a result of the bail reform
efforts have been numerous
failures to appear this puts some
guard rails um back in place if people
are
failing to appear
on the charges that they have to face
and then the last section which is
starts on the bottom of page four which
my good friend chief shigori will uh
testify to
allows for background checks for
um
that are going to be employed as peace
officers and i think that
um giving the emphasis on training and
trying to make sure that
law enforcement
by their own uh desire is um
really conducting things in a in an
aboveboard manner there should be an
opportunity to get that kind of um
employment data from a past employer so
um
let me just stress that some of the
um testimony i think you'll hear
and
what you know my sense of why this bill
is so important in particular
the provision that people
who are charged with those 10 violent
crimes or pornography which let's face
it that's a violent crime against
children
should see a judge because of what's
happened if we hadn't had incidences
of
violent behavior and then reoffending
after people getting bail
this bill would not be necessary but
it's been necessary by real world
examples of what's happened when people
have not seen a judge and have been
accused of a violent crime and then have
reoffended so let me just cite a few of
them and they'll probably be somewhat
more testimony on more examples
in nashua
there was a
unbelievable case a subject was charged
with domestic violence was released
and then return to
the home to brutalize and rape the same
victim after being released on bail
in portsmouth
a subject was involved in a vandalism
case
led police on a chase
intentionally rammed the vehicle
was arrested and released the next day
the same subject tried to set a school
on fire and was charged with arson
another example the subject was arrested
and charged with arson and stalking
released on bail and the next day the
subject stabbed a massachusetts state
trooper
the last example i would cite
is the subject was involved in a pursuit
and an assault on a police officer in
manchester he was released on bail and
thereafter was arrested in bedford for
an assault at a hotel
these are but a few of the examples
of violent
behavior
that people have
committed
alleged crimes been released and then
recommitted and that's why
i think it's so important that
um
the provision on page two of the bill
goes into effect so that those violent
crimes i think we'd all agree that those
are violent crimes
in order to get bail somebody must see a
judge so thank you very much mr chair
happy to take
your questions
yes thank you very much mr chair thank
you senator certainly um
those
four or five examples you uh cited are
horrendous but
um
is uh what would the uh
would the uh would this have a cost for
the uh
for the county jails where they have to
expand their detention cells especially
um
some of these things like uh domestic
violence that have taken a wide range of
uh
wide range of offenders some of whom
the
police probably believe rightly or
wrongly are not necessarily uh
dangerous to anyone else and the person
they
assaulted so will this uh will this have
this will require the counties to spend
more money
on spend more money under jails
i i think uh representative horgan the
purpose of detaining somebody who is
charged with a violent crime
and then the adjudication of that is to
prevent
violent crime in the future and minimize
the impact
on victims and i think the senate
position is that victims in new
hampshire need to be
protected and with the examples and i
think you will hear
many more examples from people that will
testify
subsequent to me of some very
difficult situations to say the least
of
people charged with violent crimes then
almost automatically getting pr bail and
going out and reoffending in a violent
nature again means that
we should be detaining those individuals
until a judge
has determined within 72 hours
as the statute as the proposed law
um requires
would have to go in front of a judge for
a bail here i don't think
given
the importance of protecting victims
that
that's an awful lot to ask as long as
our goal is protecting victims i hope
representative you share that goal with
me
of course follow up
well of course i i follow it so it's
like so i guess as i understand it um
you have if the bail hearing can be held
before the 72 hours send the uh
and the judge the judge rules that the
person is not dangerous um then they can
be released at that time after the bail
hearing
my understanding of the way this would
work is that within 72 hours excluding
saturdays and sundays and holidays of
course
there would have to be a here the judge
would
get to make that determination of
whether
the subject who was being detained was a
danger
to
society and should be
continue to be held until trial or could
be released
that's the way the system had always
worked until bail reform subsequent with
bail reform we're seeing um
you know these violent criminals
charged with
you know a violent crime let me put it
that way
that automatically virtually got pr bail
were released and committed another
violent offense and that's
um what i think we're trying to
minimize
obviously no system is perfect but you
know we've seen examples of where
legislation from several years ago with
the best of intentions
kind of got off the rails and so this is
a surgical fix
to protect the public and to protect
victims
okay thank you all right thank you
representative knight you're recognized
for a question
question um i
really love the fact that we're so
focused on victims we do really care
about victims this in this committee
my concern is that this uh creates
victims in the system
because we
aren't
we're not fixing the bail reform process
we're just
blaming
the few people that
that get through that make it
make things very bad for our community
yes so my my question is don't you think
that there is a potential for this
72-hour hold to create more victims than
the ones we're actually saving and open
further litigation to the state to being
sued for
unlawful imprisonment
i do not um share that concern based on
um the numbers and i think you will hear
testimony um and and i've got a long
list of
um
you know people that were released on pr
bail that went out and committed violent
crimes afterwards i don't think
for purposes of this hearing i need to
go through it that will be submitted i
believe by the
police chief from bedford as part of the
record but i think the case some of the
cases that i raised
show that we need to fix a real problem
because real people have had their lives
devastated i mean the situation in
nashua where the subject was charged
with domestic violence was released and
returned
to brutalize and rape the same victim
i think representative that calls for
a 72-hour period in which a judge as
opposed to a bail commissioner
makes that determination
that's all we're asking that is a
very surgical fix on the most serious
crimes of homicide of felonious sexual
assault
um
stalking kidnapping
pornography those crimes
rise to a level if somebody is charged
with them in my view at least where we
should be very careful and make sure
that
the person before he or she gets bail
has been in front of a judge
follow-up
for a question
can i have a follow-up chair
who did you recognize mr chair i
recognized recognize representative
newman
thank you uh mr chair and thank you
senator for taking my question um
the you listed the number of the crimes
uh that have to be considered and the
part that says they have to be
considered says that the court
and a bail commissioner shall consider
the following issues
so does that particular phrase mean that
a bail commissioner can't do it by
itself and a judge can or it's either or
what what exactly does it mean by and a
bail commissioner the court and a bail
commissioner
uh the intent of the statute is for
those crimes listed
um from on page two of the bill from
lines one through ten that that person
would have to go
um in front of a judge
in order to get um bail
okay
follow it
okay and i have just one other thing it
seems when after they consider those
conditions
it says that for a period not more than
72 hours so
i'm trying to figure out like you gave
those examples before of judges they had
discretion in that case because this
wording didn't exist
and now they still have they would still
have the possibility of personal
recognizance in this
they wouldn't necessarily have to hold
the person for 72 hours is that correct
my understanding is that that
determination
would have to be made by a judge
and that's the difference
thank you
representative hopper you're recognized
thank you mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question
and this bill
it appears you have
three separate bills in one bill
all of which in my mind
should have separate hearings why did
you want them all together
well um
i think that you could
potentially say that
number one and
section one and section four
are a little bit different than the bail
provisions
um that we've spent a lot of time this
morning talking about
um
you know because of covid
um and because there were so many bills
both filed in your chamber and in the
senate i made a determination um
to put all of these provisions in one
bill i did not think that either section
one or four
um would
sort of interfere with
um what i am trying to accomplish in
section
you know the two bail reform pieces
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking the question
something that stuck with me this term
we heard testimony earlier this year
along the lines of hard cases make bad
law
essentially
indicating that
very serious crimes that that need to
proposals to address specific cases
rather than the vast majority of
situations that
are not requiring a change in law
essentially i guess my question would be
it seems like bail reform other than a
number of
very
high profile cases is generally working
okay and i guess i'm concerned about
throwing out the baby with that water
for a few
serious crimes that could still occur
even if this change were enacted
so again
again and thank you for the question um
you know there are awful lot of um
crimes that people can get charged with
and
on page two lines one through ten those
crimes are the most serious and the most
violent
and we have seen examples of people that
have been charged with violent crimes
that have been re-released that have
been released on pr bail and reoffended
almost immediately and so
i would argue that this is indeed a very
surgical approach it's not throwing out
the baby with the bath water that the
um intent of bail reform which was to
provide
you know access to people with more
modest means to be able to get bail
has not been undermined but
at the same time
recognizing
the problems that
that law created with regard to violent
charges and then reoffending in a
violent manner that a surgical approach
to and the approach is simple one has to
be in front of a judge to get bail when
charged with those violent crimes to me
that is a
very surgical and limited approach to
the problem
that's been created
seeing no for the hands raised senator i
want to thank you for your testimony
yeah and thank you very much for
allowing me to uh
sort of jump start your other hearing
appreciate that very much and look
forward to working with the committee
thank you
at this time
the public hearing on senate bill 92
will be in recess
at this time we are now reopening the
public hearing
on senate bill 60.
this time the chair recognizes lee
copper and just a reminder your
testimony
two minutes
hello can you hear me
yes we can hear you
hi thank you for the opportunity to
speak my name is lee cooper i'm the
administrator for sanctuary atc
sanctuary atc opposes sb60 due to
language that essentially targets new
hampshire therapeutic cannabis patients
with the way that this bill is written a
qualified new hampshire therapeutic
cannabis patient with a non-psychoactive
topical product such as a sab that has
been opened and placed in their purse
could legally face dire consequences for
simply possessing a cannabis product
they purchased at an atc
similarly a driver of a vehicle with a
patient that is a passenger could face
legal consequences for the patient
opening their cbd capsule container in
the vehicle on their way home
many of our therapeutic cannabis
patients use cannabis in lieu of
traditional pharmaceuticals and these
patients and their caregivers are
allowed to legally possess therapeutic
cannabis just like they would any other
medication
as the apc for geographic zone four
which covers carol grafton and coast
county some of our patients travel over
two hours one way to acquire their
therapeutic cannabis and should not have
to place that therapeutic cannabis in
their hot trunk elevated temperatures
can damage those products
an open container of therapeutic
cannabis that a patient or caregiver
possesses should not be considered the
same as an open container of alcohol
new hampshire therapeutic cannabis
patients and caregivers should not face
a violation a fine or licensed
suspension for simply having open
container of therapeutic cannabis in
their vehicle thank you
[Music]
i want to thank you for your testimony
seeing no hands raised the witness is
excused
the chair now recognizes michael
mclaughlin
reminding you your testimony is in two
minutes
good morning mr chairman first i'll ask
the question can you hear me
yes we can here
uh
interesting enough so far this morning i
always mentioned that in uh new
hampshire law right now there's an
affirmative defense available to
qualified patients
who hold id cards uh
rxa126x5 provides a defense against
transporting uh
therapeutic cannabis what i'm trying to
point out real quickly is
sb60 is conflicting with rsa
x5 so it's really not legislatively uh
efficient to create a crime in one
section and give an indemnification to
the other so you'll see that the
affirmative defense would force a
cannabis patient to get the violation
then have to go to court spend money and
to present his affirmative defense so
early we had testimony about not having
the id card the id card does not have
your condition on it you can show your
id card show your license and you should
have no consequences uh but under senate
bill 60 you will so the early
discussions of having a uh amendment to
put therapeutic cannabis patients into
senators bill 60 as an exemption is a
good idea because otherwise you've got
two laws in direct conflict which isn't
fair to a patient to give him a ticket
and als also provide him an absolute
defense against the ticket having to go
find out in court spend money to get out
of it so hopefully that's within two
minutes but there's your conflict and
there's why this needs an amendment
i want to thank you for your testimony
thank you
you know hands raised the witness is
excused
josephson
and
tim it
when i try to uh
add you it says that
when i try to add you to speak it says
that you're using an
outdated version of zoom
for that reason
there's a number to call in
i could find for you
if i call it
[Music]
mr chair it looks like we've lost him
i don't see him on the list anymore
come on here i am
oh there we go that's why you're not on
the list
thank you for adding me on here mr chair
thank you very much uh for taking my
testimony for the for the record my name
is uh honorable tim josephson former
representative from grafton11 and i live
here in canaan uh you heard my wife
testimony testify earlier she is a
therapeutic cannabis patient and i am a
licensed caregiver um
so one of my main concerns about this
bill
is that it literally lifts the language
from rsa 265 a 44 which is about open
containers of alcohol it is literally
the same language cannabis is not
alcohol we can't just lift language from
one and put it on another especially
when cannabis is used in new hampshire
as a medication by thousands of patients
and this is a step backwards you know we
heard that we heard the police chief
talking about how different cannabis is
from alcohol so why does this bill treat
it the same um you know and and and we
talked about you know inaccessibility
and the trunk and that sort of thing
um
you know as a caregiver and as the
patient we have to carry our cards with
us all the time so you know when the
chief said there's no way for an officer
to check and see if someone has a card
that's not true we have to we have to
have our cards uh one question that i
haven't heard asked by anybody yet is
how many people have been um pulled over
or or are charged
with a dui
for uh driving under the influence of
cannabis or marijuana uh that the police
chief alluded to that it was a problem
that it was an issue
um that they've been seeing so i'm just
curious what the data is on that
um you know by definition the only the
only
sealed container has to come from an atc
in new hampshire that's the only way you
can get a sealed container um therefore
this is primarily applied to patients uh
here's an example so i'm a caregiver i'm
the driver of the car i take the patient
to the atc for a meeting because they
want to meet their uh the the people
there at the at the atc they help the
patient with selecting some gummies or
capsules and then the patient who's glad
to get some relief from their nausea
takes one as a passenger and puts the
container in their purse or bag they're
driving along and the caregiver
caregivers by the way are often the
spouse of the patient
they're driving they get pulled over for
whatever reason the police notice the
open container and then they find the
caregiver and take away their license
now we're just taking away the only way
that that patient has to get their
medicine if they're an elderly patient
and that's how they you know they they
rely on their caregiver um you know this
happens with with cancer patients who
take chemo a lot of the the use of
therapy cannabis for those type of
patients is to offset the nausea that
comes with the chemo
so you know it
it we don't treat other medications the
same way is really my point uh we we
don't have any bills we don't have any
laws to talk about prescription
medications i could have a car seat full
of prescription medications next to me
in my name that i have you know legally
access to they could all be open
and that's fine um i just asked that
this bill either be found in expedient
to legislate or retain because it is
obvious that it needs some work so thank
you and i'm happy to answer any
questions
i want to thank you for your testimony
seeing no hands raised the witnesses
excused we do miss you in the house sir
ah thank you i missed you
at this time
the channel recognizes
matt simon
hello can you hear me okay
yes
great thank you for the record matt
simon uh representing the marijuana
policy project
i oppose this bill for a lot of reasons
you've already heard but primarily
because it would be a big step backwards
for criminal justice reform in new
hampshire
this bill has been described as an
attempt to treat cannabis similarly to
the way we treat alcohol it's a very
familiar argument to me it's one that
i've been making for a long time with
regard to regulation of cannabis markets
in most respects i support treating
cannabis similarly to alcohol but in
this case there is an obvious difference
between
alcohol and cannabis and it's the
difference between a liquid and a solid
if somebody has a can of beer or a
bottle of whiskey in in the passenger
compartment of their vehicle and it's
open they're probably drinking it
with cannabis that simply isn't the case
it's more like a pack of cigarettes that
you've already taken a cigarette out of
there's no
likelihood that you're actually
consuming it just because it happens to
not be sealed
so i think it's important to remember
one of the main goals of
decriminalization was to refocus limited
law enforcement resources away from
simple possession of cannabis
encouraging police to instead focus on
serious crimes and threats to public
safety as we've heard it is already a
crime to drive while impaired
i think i also think it's very important
to remember that the proponents of this
bill
uh were staunch vigorous opponents of
the modest and very popular decrim law
that passed in 2017 in any other context
this bill's proponents oppose treating
cannabis like alcohol in this case they
seem to want to be returning to the days
when police did consider it their
business
if somebody possessed a small amount of
cannabis whether or not they were consum
consuming it or presenting a public
threat to public safety so as we
consider what the role of policing
should be in the 21st century this bill
would take new hampshire back to the
20th century by giving police a new
excuse to search people's cars absent
any threat to public safety i would
strongly encourage you to find it
inexpedient to legislate and if you're
not going to do that please retain it so
that we can argue about the many
misrepresentations that were made by the
proponents of this bill during during
earlier testimony thank you
hey
thank you for your testimony
seeing no hands raised the witnesses
excused
folks if there's any members of the
public who are in attendance if we
should testify
[Music]
regardless of senate bill 60 that have
not testified already
please raise your hand
seeing no hands raised at this time we
will
close the public hearing
on senate bill 60 representative muse
we read the results
we had 33 people who signed in in
support of this bill we had 95 who
signed in in opposition
and we had one person who signed in as
neutral
thank you very much
at this time
we are going to reopen the
public hearing on senate bill 92.
and does any members of the public more
in attendance that wish to testify
please raise your hand
so
at this time the chair recognizes chief
andrew
sigouri
and for the purposes of this the public
hearing
we're going to limit testimony three
minutes per week
thank you
uh just briefly what what i was going to
talk about was the section on um
background uh as you know the leak
commission recommended that we look at
bias and other
things that show up in background
this bit this section is modeled after a
large sar in california when i get a
request for information
i looked at it kind of
looked at what we need to do there's a
similar bill that actually i think went
through your committee already
and
went to the senate it just puts it in a
different section
the idea is that
businesses will share this information
and they get exemption from liability
and it doesn't have to be shared the
more information we get to give a better
picture
of people we're bringing into this
profession the better it will be
the other section on on i think uh
senator bradley spoke quite well about
the uh
and the uh amendments we made on the
criminal mischief so i'll
yield my time i see a question so
i think i've uh
addressed what needs to be addressed
at this time the chair recognized
representative corrigan for a question
with all the members
if you're recognized
by the chair for a question i expect a
question to be asked to witness
not i'm not a state
oh okay
um
so yeah and then
your in your experience um without this
law do
do
employers usually give you uh the type
of detailed information that
that uh
this law
is uh
attempting to give so are they usually
fairly uh
fairly circumspect what they say about
former employees
uh it's hit or miss i've had a few
occasions
one just last year where a previous
employer refused to give information um
but for the most part people do share
but they may not
they may limit what they share too they
may just say the person worked here
and uh
this is how much they made
and they may not be willing especially
if there's uh some concerns that they
could be sued this gives them
and we have to jump through certain
steps to ask it we have to do it in
writing we have to cite the law we have
to do you know cite the conditions of
the law so it's not just
we we probe people pretty hard i try to
but occasionally it has been thwarted
uh i had to look other ways to try and
get that info
hopefully this just makes it easier and
everybody feels uh comfortable sharing
that information that's critical to make
a good hiring decision
follow-up
representative morgan you're recognized
for a follow-up question
yes
and of course we have a
sub-paragraph for this section um
gives uh
tries to take away the
applicant's right to
just sue to sue um do you think that
would be uh
would that would that do you think
in your opinion which i may not be
asking the right person but your opinion
would that uh
restrict a uh applicant from suing a
out-of-state employer
it may not apply to other states i'm not
an expert on on cross state
i think it would may limit it but
i can't answer for that honestly
okay thanks thank you mr chair thank you
chief
seeing no for the hands race i want to
thank the witness first testimony
at this time the chair recognizes
lieutenant timothy patterson
good afternoon chairman abbas and
members of the committee
my name is lieutenant tim patterson and
i've been in law enforcement with
manchester police department for 24
years i am here to testify in support of
sb 92 for the manchester police
department
we see this bill as a way to tweak
existing legislation and ensure that
dangerous individuals are brought before
a judge to properly consider bail these
changes are necessary as we continue to
see dangerous individuals released on
personal recognizance bail
there is inconsistency in the
application of current law by bill
commissioners
for example earlier this week an
individual was released on pr bail after
being charged with reckless conduct with
a deadly weapon
during an argument she threw a knife in
the air striking the individual she was
arguing with
chief profonsky will detail an incident
in his testimony involving a convicted
felon who shot another individual on the
streets of manchester back in november
this individual was from massachusetts
and was also released on personal
recognizance bail
these individuals and others should have
been hailed for a bail hearing in front
of a judge so that an informed decision
can be made regarding release conditions
imposed or
the option of being held
i along with the citizens of manchester
appreciate your effort in considering
changes to bill reform and urge you to
find this bill ought to pass thank you
i want to thank you thank you for your
testimony
[Music]
seeing no hands raised
but when i think to win this first
testament
this time the chair recognizes michael
excuse me uh the two now organizes uh
alpha cheers
thank you uh mr chair um uh my name's uh
albert sher uh
i uh
my opinions
are my own i'm not uh
thinking for either unh law or durham
um brief history um
uh i was involved uh with then senator
feltes uh in uh
in the original bail reform bill uh i
served on the two bail commissions that
were formed uh after uh the the original
bail reform bill um on which there are
prosecutors
and uh police officers
and then a second bail commission which
was formed after some additional changes
uh
that second bail commission
uh the changes that that
the second bail commission had a
majority of law enforcement officers on
it um
we heard many of the same uh complaints
and anecdotes uh that you will hear
today
about that some of which uh senator uh
bradley talked about
uh i i've heard the the example senator
bradley talked about before i heard them
uh when i was on the second bail
commission the second bail commission
had a majority of law enforcement
individuals be police officers
prosecutors
or jail individuals superintendents
at the end when we arrived at a
compromise and we heard this testimony
about protecting victims when we arrived
at a compromise then senator levaik who
was chair of the committee um uh senator
representative welch and representative
woodbury were on the committee
senator senator levaik said does anyone
want to add any more anything more to
what we've crafted
everybody
nobody said yes
does anyone want to make any changes
nobody said yes does everybody agree
with what we've drafted
nobody's everybody said yes
those
those changes went into effect on
september 17th of this past year 2020
we have nowhere near enough data
at all
to
say let's tweak what we just tweaked
seven months ago we don't have that
information and i strongly urge the
committee not to not to pass this
legislation to vote uh itl on this
legislation because it's an effort
to legislate by anecdote
and that's a mistake
uh and uh we worked hard on the bail
commission we met at le met at least 10
times to try and accommodate all the
concerns everybody had from both sides
of the criminal criminal justice system
and we did a good job and now
here comes the uh police chiefs and
others back saying
we got to make changes because we didn't
really mean it when we agreed with what
we
what you did last year we got some more
changes so
i urge uh that you vote in expedient to
legislate
thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes representative
hopper for a question
uh thank you mr chairman thank you thank
you professor for uh taking my question
so the the example that the senator gave
were they outdated
and um you know were they
with those before
uh the effects of the law took place
i remember uh
somebody in a presentation to the bail
commission talking about at least two
about at least two of those examples
um and and you know
senator bradley for whatever reason uh
didn't date those examples
i think
some of the examples he gave as i
understood them back then
and would have been uh uh
the outcome would have been different if
uh the current version had been in place
at that time that's why uh
these outdated examples uh are really
not useful because we heard a lot about
the very
problem senator bradley talked about on
the bail commission and we as a group we
work really hard to
um
to figure that out and accommodate it
both in terms of failures to appear
and in terms of
potential uh dangerous people being
released
thank you
china recognize representative
pantholakis for a question
muted
uh
thank you for mr chairman and
mr shirt
in your um
in your
package or whatever you want to call it
that i've never seen
um did you put in it a cooling off
period for people that had beat other
people or domestic violence or anything
like that
the the bail commission uh the proposals
uh
sought to empower better to make
it clear
uh several things one that bail
commissioners who are the first people
who set bail
bail commissioners have all the
authority that a judge has in setting
bail uh and that was the case back then
and and the problem has been that bail
commissioners um have not been
uh have not been getting paid and it's
been hard to find
uh good bail commissioners who will uh
uh who will accept training and do it
simply because they're not getting paid
and so that's been the choke point in
terms of dangerous people getting relief
um that and the the the superior court
system and the district court system
which supervises bail commissioners had
had a strong commitment and made a
strong commitment in the uh during the
bail commission to training the bail
commissioners better so
that's the way uh
we the bail co the bail commission tried
to address that problem rather than a
dramatic change like this
representative antelope is recognized
for a follow-up question yes uh you
you say that they didn't put in any
stipulation of somebody being held for a
certain length of time to cool them off
it just left it the way it was to the
bail commission
it it it directed the
district courts to educate bail
commissioners about the powers they have
and to you know be
exercised their powers to hold somebody
temporarily um uh
we
decided that there was no
need given what we had heard for a
cooling off period uh and there are the
way this is written this uh this uh the
way this pro
proposal uh sb92 is written it may well
be unconstitutional to include a
presumption against release for certain
crimes
so there's ways to do cooling off
periods and there's other ways to do
them some of them are unconstitutional
which i think is a substantial concern
with this when you build in a
presumption against release
so
yes there's no formal cooling off period
and what the bail commission did but we
thought about it we talked about it and
we decided to focus better on bail
commissioners and in fact uh i think sb
uh if i'm not mistaken
sb 490a
uh is making its way uh through the
legislature which ensures that bail
commissioners will get paid betterment
yes i'm not interested in whether they
get paid or not i think they need to be
told that if a man is beating his wife
after death
he should not be released on
permanent whatever it is pr
because this is a very dangerous
situation not only defects the wife but
it also affects the children
i agree i agree completely uh
representative panalakas
and i think that does not happen very
very often at all and the court system
is
doing more and more to empower
the bail commissioners so they
understand that and i don't think i
think it's too soon
to uh
make yet another very significant tweak
uh to this legislation before we get
better data as to how often that has
occurred
thank you
representative newman you're recognized
for a question
thank you mister and thank you uh
for taking my question
um could could you just you say we don't
have any data could you just uh
address specifically
how um the
the bill has been changed that has what
effect it has
on the ability to give pr uh instead of
bail
um is that weakened or or improved by
this bill or what uh
it is
uh it is
i'm trying to find i'm trying to say
two things at once so i'll try and pick
them apart um
can't hear you
oh i don't know
okay i'm sorry i'm not sure what
happened
it it takes a
a group of ten or so crimes and
categorically says
you can you the presumption is you're
not going to get pr bail until you see
uh and and you've got to see a judge
um
so it takes away access uh
in a substantial number of circumstances
it will take away access to pr bail for
those group of people and and one of the
problems representative newman is
that
categorically using categories of crimes
is not an effective way to do it there
are
certain kinds of assaults that uh are
frightening and dangerous and the huge
majority of judges i've seen in my
tracking how these prevail hearings work
out
will hold people for that kind of
first-degree assault but then there's
other kinds of first-degree assaults
that are a unique circumstance there are
one off and that
they're not you know they're not going
to be dangerous and they'll lose their
job if they're held for three days
before particularly if it's over a
weekend which extends into
so yeah that's the balance here there
the original bail reform act and the two
revisions that occurred
have always focused on empowering the
individual bail commissioner and the
individual judge to decide each case on
its merits
and by categorizing
a certain number of crimes it takes that
power away from the bail commissioner
and the judge so yes it reduces
access to pr bail when you categorize
crimes
thank you
[Music]
thank you for taking my question
um
one thing is i think this this can be a
little bit confusing for people who
haven't been tracking with the with the
journey of bail reform over time um
one of the things that um
you know that i'm wondering is if is if
you might be able to
uh fairly quickly take us through
um uh
kind of how we got to this place and and
why these specific exemptions uh in your
opinion uh
really aren't uh
uh aren't wise i guess at this point in
time i i understand the focus on bail
commissioners what i'm what i'm
struggling with a little bit is that
these do seem like very serious issues
um
and uh i just want to make sure that
that i understand
uh that we're not doing something uh
that we're being as pragmatic as
possible and that we're not just basing
you know decisions on
ideology or what we would like to see
happen but we're really basing them on
what's happening in the real world um i
will uh uh uh uh chair abbas uh will i'm
sure remind me uh i have difficulty
doing pretty quickly
okay but i'll do the best i can pretty
quickly uh three three getting on four
years ago now uh bail legislation was
introduced
uh to target primarily to target the
problem of
people um people who are being held on
500 or 250 or a thousand dollars bail
not because they were dangerous
but because they just are there at risk
of fleeing because they didn't have the
money uh to meet that uh they were being
held because of they were poor
that was one of the primary
focuses of the original bail reform
accompanying that one of the other
primary focuses
was a concern for people who are a
danger to themselves or others and we
expanded in the original bailiff reform
act uh the number of people to all
crimes uh misdemeanors and felonies any
crime a person could be held without
bail if if the judge if it could be
shown by clear and convincing evidence
that they were dangerous that was a huge
expansion of the opportunity
or the power of a court for that matter
a bail commissioner to hold people
without bail
and uh and that's been happening at uh a
far greater rate best we can tell from
the what little data we've been able to
connect collect that's been happening
since bail reform post bail reform a lot
more people are being held without bail
that were ever held without bail before
so that's the original bail reform the
original bail form act recognized that
this was a significant shift in the way
things had been done
and therefore it put in place the bail
commission to deal with
expected tweaks that were needed
uh and so the first bail uh reform uh
bail commission made some tweaks that
were passed i believe in the
two thousand uh
uh
eighteen 18 2019 session um
that made it easier
easier for prosecutors not to have to
call
victims
that in the first instance empowered
empowered judges
uh to uh to
uh extend the detention for a brief
period of time
in order uh for the prosecution in the
defense to collect evidence when a
detention hearing uh when uh was being
held
uh and uh and it it tweaked the issue of
how do we deal with failures to appear
that was a source of great conversation
so those tweets were passed in the 1819
session
it also proposed that the bail
commission continued to sit
um the bail commission that went in
place in the eight the
1920 session
uh was com a little different it had
more police it had more prosecutors uh
it had
uh some jail superintendent
um and it had a bail commissioner on it
uh and it continued to look at the issue
of failures to appear uh and it
continued to look at the issue of
dangerousness
and
that's where we ended up with what is
now in effect that went into effect
signed by the governor on june 17th last
year went into effect september 17th 60
days after
so that's where we are now
and
um i think we need to be careful about
adopting changes
that have not been vetted in
the way the two previous uh waves of
changes of tweaks have been vetted those
were all the tweaks were comprehensively
benefited with stakeholders from every
every part of the spectrum uh
talking about it in a very practical way
and one of my difficulties with the
process here is that these are tweaks
that are not gonna do not get that kind
of
representative muse you're recognized
for a follow-up question yes just one
one quick follow-up when you say that
the changes uh haven't been vetted this
time around
um how is the process different between
the set of tweaks that senator bradley
is recommending and the set of tweaks
that were implemented in the last
session
uh
the tweaks that senator which yeah
they're more than tweaks this is the
biggest change that's been proposed to
bail commission the the the big changes
that senator bradley is proposing uh
have not gone through a conversation at
a bail commission with all the
stakeholders present
where we talk about language we propose
changes a language gets changed we
listen to witnesses we listen to police
on the commission prosecutors who
testify who are on the commission
uh
it just hasn't gone through that very
solid comprehensive process
and it needs to do that this is a tough
it's a tough issue
uh it is
you know we're talking about public
safety and we're talking about putting
people in jail who have not been found
guilty people who are presumed innocent
for an extended period of time before
trial and both of those are incredibly
powerful instincts in each of us and
we need to be really careful before we
make as dramatic a change as senator
bradley is proposing
thank you
mr morgan you were recognized for a
question
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much professor chair i'm
i'm actually uh president of hopper you
recognize red hopper myself from a
judiciary committee he was reassigned
this year but i'm just here for the day
and i see i have to educate more
how this works um
so the bail commissioner
the bill commissioner basically makes a
uh initial decision so it seems to me
just looking quickly at the rsa while i
was listening is multitasking it looks
like the state already can
ask for
a field bail commissioner's decision if
they feel the person should not be
released i'm not sure
uh so
before i got to the question so
professor share is that a
so you're saying your opinion this is a
that's a sufficient remedy in case the
bill commissioner makes a recommendation
that it
that the state disagrees with yeah the
bail commissioner uh has all the powers
that a judge has by statute they have
all the powers that a judge has in
setting bail and the police what's
interesting is
generally speaking the only person that
appears in front of the bail
commissioner in addition to the the
suspect defendant is the police a police
officer
although now it turns out
they
sometimes county attorneys seem to be
assistant county attorneys seem to be
appearing but if the police or the
county attorney disagrees with what the
bail commissioner did
they can um
they can go into court that same day
let's assume the bail commissioner set
bail at two in the morning they can get
into superior court at nine the next day
um to uh to try and get that reviewed um
follow up
follow up mr chair yes
you're recognized for a follow-up
question
of course yes i understand
um
are the bill commissioners necessarily
uh more uh
more lenient than the than the judges
since of course
even if we pass this bill the judge can
still release somebody on personal
recognizance or even
on cash bail and then somebody can
reoffend after paying the cash bail so
are you are the bill commissioners more
lenient than the judges
uh
you know the the good law professor
answer that's not useful is it depends
uh you know i think uh just like some
judges are more lenient or more strict
than other judges the same is true with
bail commissioners uh but i i emphasize
once again they have all the powers of
the judge and there's no defense lawyer
there uh bark
bengal commissioners here it's uh it's
the police yeah and
i i think we need
to wait and and see how the efforts on
part of the judiciary uh the district
court system in particular
uh go in terms of better educating uh
the bail commissioners which they've
committed to doing uh in front of the
last bale commission which is seven
months is not enough time
okay thank you professor thank you mr
chair
chair recognizes representative klein
knight for a question
question
so
am i hearing that a lot of the concerns
that the police chief and the senator
are holding could simply be
we could simply be amending these
concerns
with
reforming uh
bail commissioners education and making
a mandatory education process
there is a somewhat mandatory education
process are already in place
historically
it was not used very aggressively uh
uh
judge uh david david king the chief
judge
of the circuit court system committed at
front of the bail commission
to being much more aggressive about the
education process so i i'm always in
favor of education of judges and bail
commissioners and i would be very
supportive of formalizing even more the
education of bail commissioners
rather than taking the dramatic step
that this legislation proposes
represent klein knight do a follow-up
question
um no i wave off thank you
see you know for the hands raised i want
to thank the witness first testimony in
new york's youth
thank you mr chairman
cheer recognize
these names as bedford new hampshire
police but you were recognized
please say your state your full name
yes uh good afternoon mr chairman mr
chairman and member of the committee my
name is john berfonsky i am the chief of
police here in bedford hampshire going
on 10 years with
almost 43 years
of continuous law enforcement service
to the granite state and the united
states
i represent the new hampshire
association of chiefs of police we are
in solid support of this bill
and the provisions of this bill members
of the committee
this bill is about the safety of you and
everyone in the state i'm sure and your
constituents it's about the victims of
crime and it's time to put the victims
ahead of suspected criminals
victims are not anecdotes they are real
people with real hurt real injuries
in real families they are not anecdotes
these are real cases you heard from the
manchester police department
representative who testified about a
case that happened this very week
it is about making sure that we take
expedient make expedient changes to the
bail law as senator bradley uh so aptly
stated in a surgical sense so that we
can protect victims of crime
it is about victims of crime and without
um belaboring the point i want to bring
up the cases that some of the other
folks who provided testimony mentioned
that i have the first case is a november
case a recent case with respect to an
individual from massachusetts who came
to new hampshire he was a convicted
felon a prohibited possessor of firearms
he shot an individual
and was released and put back on the
street immediately a clear danger to the
to the community
other cases nashua you'll hear and may
have heard about the horrendous case
that senator bradley mentioned about an
individual who was released and went
back and brutalized the victim
and raped that same victim in portsmouth
you heard the case regarding the
vandalism another subject was charged
with the receiving stolen property and
released on bail arrested on the same
charge and breach of bail released and
charged again with receiving stolen
property released again and had a
similar record in concord in newport new
hampshire suspected drug dealers chased
and shot at two teenagers and the
shooter was released on person recalling
the simpson king
a felon fell and stabbed another person
was arrested and released on personal
recognizance and franklin a subject was
arrested 10 times on various charges
including domestic violence stalking and
released on personal recognizance a
subject in franklin was arrested on
seven counts of breached bail two counts
of domestic violence criminal
threatening and released on pr bail
in lebanon the subject pointed a gun at
the head of a female and was released on
pr bail in haverhill a subject assaulted
his spouse discharged a firearm in the
house where the children were present
and were released on pr bill a subject
again was arrested in haverhill seven
times on felony offenses released on
prbl each time in concord the subject
was arrested for breach of bail twice
including stalking and released on pr
bail a subject was arrested and charged
with arson and stalking and released on
pr bill and as the senator indicated the
next day stabbed in massachusetts
oh i do have to ask the witness to
conclude their testimony
i do i do recognize representative klein
knight to ask the question of the
witness
okay
thank you um sir for taking my question
what was the chief of police involvement
in the past commission that the previous
witness spoke about
well again uh the there were
representatives uh on that particular
commission and um i wasn't on the
commission but i can tell you
that
we had predicted that some of these
consequences would occur
uh but nevertheless as was previously
testified to there was a compromise and
again although we predicted that these
incidences incidents would occur and
they have
um whether or not we look back and
attempt to
determine recriminations or who was
present or not present
i want to emphasize that the cases and
victims are real
uh today um and we need to address the
victims of crime today
not about who was on what commission
later on with all due respect
great thank you i have a follow-up sir
representative you were recognized for a
follow-up question
thank you do you have the data
of how things were conducted before the
previous law wasn't enacted let's say
all these cases you spoke about i want
to know how many have happened since we
passed this last year's bail reform and
how many that have happened before then
because you want to have the same law
come back i want to see if the numbers
are really different or not
i wish i could tell you that it would be
an easy thing to do to be able to make
that data call um you have 177 or more
police departments with various records
management systems and the state system
that makes it very difficult to be able
to determine the answers to that
question but i can tell you that in a
data call and just from cases that we
receive from the chiefs of police
throughout the state these are recent
cases these are cases that are occurring
each and every day and as the senator
indicated these are cases that
surgically uh um focus on only the most
violent criminals um on the streets of
new hampshire each and every day so it
should be easy to get that data of how
many of you are not recognized for a
third question
representative newman you're right you
were recognized for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you chief
um
i just have a basic question given that
it's up to 72 hours here and
it involves it sounds like the bail
commissioner and the court
um could you just
tell us what's different
what actually would be different if this
law were to pass
than in all of that list of cases you
you
uh told us about
where
either a judge or a bail commissioner
released
a person
and how this bill would constrain the
release of that person if it were passed
i'm having a hard time seeing the
difference
thank you for the question
and it's very simple bail commissioners
have a very wide degree of latitude they
take their instructions from judges and
they may apply those uh the way that
they see fit and despite the urgings of
police officers at the scene bail
commissioners as you've seen in these
cases have continually released people
who have been arrested with very clear
evidence beyond probable cause that they
engage in a violent crime and so the
changes in this particular bill
would
require that there be an argument a
legal argument not necessarily 72 hours
it could occur the next day if it
occurred during the weekday the 72-hour
provision is to take into account a
weekend and a holiday so this could
occur within 12 hours let's say of the
act occurring or even less but let's
talk about the fact that this uh is an
opportunity for a legal argument to be
made before a judge with better
information from both the defense
attorney as well as the assistant county
attorney these are serious crimes these
are a felony crimes that are going to be
prosecuted by
the superior by the assistant county
attorneys not by police prosecutors
these are serious felony crimes and
let's have that um argument before a
judge in a courtroom so that the um
neutral magistrate can make the proper
decision as to whether or not to release
someone who shot up the streets of
manchester
representative newman you were
recognized for a follow-up question
thank you uh mr chair uh
the follow-up question is
were all of the cases that you told us
about um as a result of the bail
commissioner
uh doing the release uh
or was were some of them released by
judges and would that have an effect on
the judge's ability to give vr
would it be any different
the judge is the final arbiter of making
a determination as to whether or not an
individual
is a danger to the community or a risk
of flight so in the final analysis it's
the neutral magistrate that we want that
here that the proponents of this bill
want to make the decision the neutral
magistrate not a bail commissioner
without all the facts
and as to the dates
again we do have some dates i'm not
prepared to provide those dates because
they're in another data system but if
you need those dates we could probably
go back and try to find the dates to the
cases that we do have
well that's fine i was just
worried about the difference between the
judge and the bail commission thank you
representative muse
you're recognized for a question
yes
thanks for taking my question my
understanding is that bail commissioners
um
basically are
uh
are instructed not to release people uh
who may be a danger to themselves and
others and that's basically our current
law
so it it seems like there's obviously a
failure
somewhere
and
attorney share alluded to the fact that
training has been inconsistent with with
bail commissioners
what it seems like this law would do is
to take certain cases out of their hands
um
i i guess what i'm what i'm curious
about is what your experience has been
in general on cases like this when you
work with bail commissioners are cases
like this um really a very very minor
exception to the rule
uh because i i think sometimes it sounds
like you know these cases are happening
you know all the time they're happening
left and right they're happening more
often than not
but kind of getting to what i i think
representative knight was getting at
what i'm trying to get a better and
clearer understanding of is
what percentage of the of these types of
cases
um you know to the examples that you're
giving really sort of fallen into you
know how prevalent are they
well um i don't think anyone is equipped
um today
to provide the answer with respect to
the percentage
just the number of cases that came to
the chiefs association from various
chiefs throughout the state
and these are only a smattering of those
cases uh there are more
but the reality is uh and thank you for
the question let us focus on the
severity of the charge in the crimes
involved hopefully we're talking about a
very small percentage of cases overall
and they probably are when we talk about
the total number of a and b felony cases
charged and a and b misdemeanor cases
charged every single day let us hope in
the granite state that these are very
few cases but again these are the cases
that involve serious bodily injury and
potential death to victims and that is
the difference we don't want this to
occur anymore today tomorrow or the next
day when we have victims that are
brutalized shot at on and nearly killed
on on the streets of the granite state
it's about the severity of the crime and
the victims
thank you
representative
you were recognized for a question
thank you very much mr chair thank you
much for your chief i asked um attorney
share a similar question it looks like
there there already is a uh at the time
of the bail commissioners
hearing an opportunity for the state
which i assume would normally
mean the uh
police officer to uh appeal the hearing
so why is and then um then the judge
would would get it uh shortly thereafter
so why
why isn't the existing remedy sufficient
thank you
thank you for your question well there's
a bit of a misnomer there because a bail
commissioner walks into the bedford
police station at 2 a.m
and makes a determination to release
someone on pr bail and that person walks
out the door one case the person walked
out the door and threw a brick through
our window
and was rearrested again
um so there is no hearing with the bail
commissioner the bail commissioners
independently make a determination with
respect to whether or not the subject
should be released or presented on bail
or not
and oftentimes they may or may not
listen to
the
the request from the officer in charge
typically a sergeant or trooper or
deputy sheriff or a police officer
or not it's not a hearing
they make those decisions independently
all law enforcement and the proponents
of this bill are asking for is for the
most serious crimes in which serious
bodily injury or death are in play to
reserve that judgment before a judge a
neutral magistrate as soon as possible
but no later than 72 hours
okay thank you
representative fine knight
you are recognized to ask a question
thank you so much i'm just having a
really hard time understanding if crimes
that are committed in our state are so
heinous
they're not being documented for data
purposes that makes me really troubled
can you speak about that
i'm sure they're being documented the
question is how do we get that
information out of whatever database it
may be in um and so to be able to
determine how many people
have been rearrested on breach of bail
charges or how many people have been
arrested for assault one or uh robbery
or assault with a deadly weapon would
require a data call search
of a statewide database and then a hand
search of those particular
cases to determine um
whether or not the individual was
released on personal recognizance and if
so who made that decision to release the
individual
it would be great if we had one central
records management system
in the state of new hampshire with the
granularity to be able to
pull that information out quickly we
don't have it i'm not aware of it we
don't we don't even have it here in
bedford we would have to do a hand
search here of our own records
management system to be able to pull
that out going into the court system
would even be worse because they have
very disparate
management systems in the county
attorney's office for example here in
hillsborough which handles the most
cases in the state it would require a
hand
search you so much for answering all
that that makes it a lot clearer that we
have more of
no you're not you're not recognized to
make a statement
[Music]
i have a follow-up sir
represent remember representative
i'm recognizing your last follow-up
question this way thank you so much
thank you officer for explaining our
technology issues so what i'm hearing is
we shouldn't be putting people's lives
and changing the constitution we should
be updating our technology so we can
track this data properly across the
state and keep our people safe
is that true we should be focusing on
updating our technology
in our police systems versus changing
the law that protects our citizens
with all due respect representative
technology has nothing to do with the
safety of individuals in this particular
case it all has to do with making the
right decision when an individual has
been charged with a crime that could
result in the death
of someone else here in the grand states
that's what this case is about
again victims are not anecdotes they are
real people
see no hands raised i want to thank the
witness for his testimony
thank you mr chairman
the chair now recognizes michael
carrigan
and to remind the witness that testimony
will be limited to three minutes
good morning everyone mr chairman and
committee members can you hear me okay
yes we can hear you thank you sir my
name is michael carrickman i am the
chief of police for the nashua police
department i'm here today representing
the association for the chiefs of police
in the nashville police department
i will be brief i would i'm going to try
not to reiterate a lot of what chief
profonsky just said
i'm trying to give to you a perspective
of what the reality is that law
enforcement has to deal with as opposed
to the academic
thoughts out there as to how the system
is working
uh in december of 2020 which was several
months after the june
legislation changes nashville police
department received a call for domestic
assault that was in progress the suspect
had showed up at a female's house with a
gun and proceeded to force his entry in
there and assaulted her several times we
placed him under arrest and secured the
firearm as evidence
after we gave assistance to the victim
and we gave her a lethality assessment
protocol which is best practice for
domestic violence victims
she checked off every box every single
box indicating that she was the highest
risk of danger from the suspect
so we brought him in for booking
we tried three times to convince the
bail commissioner that this person was
dangerous and couldn't be released three
times we explained to him what the what
his past was and how she triggered on
the lap forms he didn't want to hear it
he said that it doesn't change anything
and he was released on two hundred
dollars bail this suspect then got out
returned to the victim's house forced
his way in and proceeded to beat her and
rape her for the remainder of the night
after he was again arrested he made full
admissions to these charges so i'm here
to give you a concrete example of
you know i'm hearing a lot about
protecting the citizens and protecting
everybody's rights well i had to look at
this young lady in the eye and explain
to her why she was raped after we didn't
keep this person in jail and i'm
struggling with listening to um the
system is working fine and we need more
time we need more data i believe that uh
we owe it to the sick to the victims um
to protect them and i think law
enforcement has
has to be respected in the fact that
they're on scene they have a
an idea of what actually happened they
can articulate why these people need to
be in the build commissioners they show
up when they're called they look at a
anything if at all and then they release
them and i struggle with them being able
to do that i'm happy to entertain any
questions i appreciate you listening
representative true you're recognized
for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
certainly not denying that the example's
given are horrible examples but in the
example you just gave
seems like the bail commissioner made a
bad decision
was there any
follow-up penalty or assessment to the
bail commissioner for that bad decision
no there is there is not and nor has
there been ever any um
uh disciplinary issues or re-education
on the bail commissions that we're aware
of
we
spent our time
um trying to get him to reconsider his
decision based on what we saw and this
is i gave you an extreme example a
horrible example but but an example
nonetheless this happens on a daily
basis regular basis people that we've
arrested 6 7 8 11 12 13 times and
they're always getting out on bail and
we're asking them not to do it we're
getting complaints from the public that
these people keep reappearing
and causing the same problems and
they're getting re-released getting
re-released i understand the concept and
i think law enforcement basically agrees
with the concept of
making sure people are not held in jail
necessarily until their trial
against their will through
whether it be socio-economic means or
whatever but you have to understand that
there are there's a common sense factor
in here that is ignored and we have to
deal with that as law enforcement
officers
thank you
representative hopper you were
recognized for a question
thank you mr chair are there any uh
statistics kept on what failed
commissioner is
uh the results of their actions um like
is there any way we trade male
commissioners is
to their uh
so sir a little bit the question was a
little bit broken up but i appreciate it
and i think i understood the question is
there any statistics or is there any
accountability for the bill
commissioners
unfortunately i can't answer it because
we don't have control of the bail
commissioners as a police department or
any of the other local police
departments and again i'm going to
reiterate what chief rufonski said it's
really difficult due to various types of
record management systems in the time
effort it would take to dial in on each
individual case to ask certain questions
and get that data um to give you a
formalized answer uh in in a report what
we're giving you and we're trying to
give you is the reality of what we're
dealing with
thank you mr chairman
thank you uh
chief kerrigan for taking my question my
question is when you deal with the bail
commissioners and they let's say
don't they make the bad decision as
representative said
what requests do you have
so the only the recourses that we have
would be to
explain to a judge that's willing to
listen that or the head bail
commissioner that we had these issues
but i think all law enforcement has been
dealing with it falling on deaf ears and
really while this is bail reform this is
the very format you can't do anything
about it so we've been kind of uh
hamstrung for it representative gathered
and i appreciate the question
representative jeff are you recognized
for a follow-up question okay if i
understood you correctly
your resource is to the uh to a judge
correct
well the head bail commissioner would be
the starting point i believe
and i think i forget who's i don't know
who's in charge currently from my role
of the bail commissioners out of nashor
district
but that's who we would go to
newman you're recognizing and for the
members that participating on zoom it is
easier for the chair to recognize you
raise your uh digital hand or your zoom
handle whatever you want to refer to it
as
it's easy for me to track even if you're
in the room it's actually easy
representing new york thank you
thank thank you mr chair i'll try to uh
get my
virtual hand going here
um thank you uh chief corrigan for
taking that uh taking my question
um i'm having a little confusion about
well let me ask you this way
where the bill now says it will be
that the court and the bail commissioner
have to
[Music]
consider these uh specific cases
to determine that whether they keep the
person for 72 hours or the hearing
within 72 hours
um
is
does that in your mind say that it seems
like that the
judge will always hear it if this bill
is passed is that your understanding
at some point the judge will have to
hear it within the 72 hours and like
chief burfonsky said it could be earlier
if it's a tuesday night at two o'clock
in the morning that judge would hear it
wednesday at the uh at the appointed
time either at nine or at one um so that
it would be heard earlier
but
it should be if we if if the law
enforcement was able to articulate
why they needed to be held and be
respected for that then the then we
would have to wait for a judge to review
all the facts and that is where the
disconnect seems to be happening in my
opinion and
follow up
you recognize for a follow-up
uh
so am i correct in in thinking that um
that where it says up to 72 hours that
that 72 hours only applies to
the time between they're arrested and
the time they have a hearing
and it is not a limitation
on the time that they may be detained
is that correct
i apologize representative newman i'm
not sure i understand the question we
have we are asking to be able to hold
them until we can get in front of a
judge for up to 72 hours because that's
the time frame that would allow us to be
able to do that to get in front of a
judge given the holidays given a weekend
and a holiday
thank you
representative recognized
[Music]
shows up for their judicial hearings and
their process
their court dates
sounds like from you and others that
it's being used as a crime-fighting
mechanism i'm curious you could
clarify that
uh representative i'm sorry you you
broke up at the first part of your
question so i didn't hear it
i don't i guess i don't understand what
you mean by a crime-fighting technique
we're asking if if somebody's arrested
for a crime we have probable cause to
believe there's a crime and we believe
this is dangerous we need to be able to
articulate that to the bail commissioner
to be able to hold that person until
they can go in front of a judge and they
can fax can be presented in front of the
judge to assess that dangerousness
thank you
recognizes representative o'hara
for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
and i'm going to try to award it in ways
so
regards the 72-hour hold
excluding
weekends and holidays
and it's only for certain crimes
and i'm probably going to age myself but
are we just going back uh to where once
was uh
for most other crimes uh that you could
hold them over the weekend um
for some and up to 72 hours
well
we're not asking to hold everybody for
72 hours we're asking if we can
articulate a reason that they should be
held that that be respected and we'd be
able to do that or have more say in it
and that's just not happening and as a
result
some seriously dangerous people are
getting out and causing more damage
you have a follow-up question
no i'm awesome
[Music]
representative klein knight you were
recognized for a question
thank you chairman thank you chief for
taking my question
my question is in regards to
representative uh
gathright's question which is
if your next course of action is to
speak to the the head or the of the
board commission in your city or town
and you don't even know their name how
many times have you actually taken that
course of action
well representative i guess to answer
that question i'm representing the
entire agency of 178 officers so i don't
have a dealing where it's it's my role
to do that we have people at several
levels that do that what how i would
answer the call is
when there's a problem and we try to
address it and it falls on deaf ears
time and time again for all law
enforcement agencies then
you really don't know what to do other
than to
go to the state legislature and testify
that you need to build the change and be
amended which is i believe what we're
doing here
say no for the hands raised i want to
thank the witness for assessment
thank you everyone
if there's any members of the public
that are in attendance that we should
testify that have not testified already
uh please raise your hand the china
recognizes ross conlon
absolutely thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for holding
this hearing for the record my name is
ross connolly i'm the deputy state
director for americans for prosperity in
new hampshire
and i'm here today to voice our
opposition to sb 92 as it's currently
written
this bill will unnecessarily limit
judicial discretion in ways that won't
benefit public safety and it will
increase jail populations
as chief justice william rehnquist
stated in our society liberty is the
norm and detention prior to trial or
without trial is the carefully limited
exception
this bill is moving new hampshire
further towards the opposite and this
will harm poor and minority communities
the most there are ways to strike a
balance to protect public safety but
this is a machete when a scalpel is
needed
and there's quite a few uh issues that
we have with this bill and out of the
interest of time uh i just want to
highlight a couple so on page 2 lines
31-32
it's good the amended language improve
this
provision
with the timeline but it is still
problematic uh first the language is
contradictory and will cause confusion
it says there is a presumption that
release won't reasonably assure
appearance but then it also says the
person shall be detained which isn't a
presumption it's a requirement
second it should be under the discretion
of the judge to determine whether
pre-trial detention is appropriate a
presumption here with a statement on the
record for why release is okay would be
a much better route
failure to appear is also a product of
poverty in many cases and doesn't
necessarily indicate a person's risk to
the public or that they will be a flight
risk now if they weren't a flight risk
three three years ago
common reasons for not appearing are bad
or no transportation obligations at work
forgetting or child issues a de facto
detention will only exacerbate these
issues and make people fall deeper into
poverty and cause a greater likelihood
of later criminal activity
and then on page 3 lines 4 through 14
requiring automatic pre-trial detention
for anyone accused of a class a
misdemeanor a third felony or a dui
is a
a terrible provision that will not
improve public safety and will only
further exacerbate the issues we
discussed
a
presumption is is fine but taking
judicial discretion away in this manner
is absolutely unnecessary unnecessary
and will set new hampshire back and it
flies in the face of of due process and
then lastly on page 3 lines 15 through
uh this provision to implement a
requirement that there is some
presumption that the person is a danger
anytime a defendant requests a
subsequent bail hearing once again
disregards due process and doesn't even
make much sense what triggers this
presumption
just asking for a hearing should not be
punished
and it's for these structural issues
along with some others
with this legislation that we urge the
committee to move sb 92 in expedient to
legislate and i'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you for your testimony the chair
and i recognize representative tanta
lockus for a question
it gets us all don't worry
do you believe mr conley do you believe
that a police officer walking into a
room
and seeing a woman's face all bloody
doesn't constitute them knowing what's
going on
uh thank you for the question
representative i i think uh a little
confused by the question but
really our our main opposition with this
bill are those uh
points that i i highlighted
we do believe that there are
improvements that can be made to to the
current bail system uh and we're happy
to to help provide those to the
committee and and be of assistance uh
for this legislation or further
legislation uh but
the the the issues regarding due process
are are pretty severe uh in our regard
in the current version of this bill
second question
president david should recognize for a
follow-up question thank you
um mr connolly
would would this not be
how would we say that it was not
um
dangerous
for everybody
involved to see this person
excuse me how could the police say that
it wasn't dangerous
uh thanks thank you for the question
representative i i think uh there
certainly for for dangerous criminals
things of that sort there there uh
should be special provisions and again
that's that's not our main disagreement
with this bill our main disagreement is
around
uh those those sections that i i
highlight uh
in my testimony
thank you
representative true you're recognized
for a question thank you mr chair and
thank you for taking my question
i i i made the wrong copy of the bill so
when you refer to second line two page
uh line 31
i don't have numbers on mine could you
for my benefit could you tell me the
worst part of the bill
and and slowly tell me where that is in
the bill so i can follow along with your
disagreement
absolutely uh
so it's on uh page two on on both the
amended version and the uh original
version
uh it's under
section
two starting with if the court
determines by a preponderance and ends
with and the person shall be
detained in pre-trial detention
and then on the third page
it's under section c starting with
failure of a person to abide by previous
bail conditions
and ending with
uh the court may consider any relevant
factors in its
making in making its determination
and then the section directly below that
which is section 4
paragraph a
thank you very much
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for testimony
thank you very much for your time
at this time the chair recognizes joseph
hello can you hear me
and just a reminder
okay thank you very much chip um thank
you chair and members of this committee
for hearing my testimony today my name
is joseph lascaux and i will be
representing the american civil
liberties union in opposition to sb 92
the aclu strongly disagrees with the
proposed bail provisions as it reflects
it is reflective of only a single
perspective and disregards the concerns
raised by other stakeholders of the bail
commission
this bill does not reflect the
recommendations that were put forward by
the bail commission nor was it previewed
with the majority of the bail commission
stakeholders including the aclu
the bail system was never intended or
designed to be punitive however that is
exactly what sb 92 does
unless you're sentenced to serve time in
jail you're supposed to be treated and
presumed innocent until proven guilty in
a court of law
however reality is that's just not the
case
jail is not an environment where people
should have to sit just because they are
poor
new hampshire can't be a place that
accepts or condones this practice
and i do want to
take time to acknowledge and recognize
that our concerns must be balanced with
community safety and that is why i want
to re-highlight the fact that our
current bail system provides our courts
and bail commissioners the authority and
means by which to detain someone pending
the resolution of their case they have
the ability to do this and just as the
burden is on the state to prove
someone's guilt the burden should be on
the state to prove someone's
dangerousness
um we heard testimony today that you
know we should be using common sense and
i i think it's common sense you know and
i'll use myself as an example if i'm
arrested for um for an offense that i
haven't been convicted of i can't prove
that i'm not something if i'm not what
i'm not um
so
i i i that that's just a a big concern
um sb 92 does take away the ability for
cases to be evaluated on a unique and
individual basis
and we hear about uh
these horrible egregious
cases
because negativity has been something
that uh is sensationalized by the media
however we don't talk about the
positive cases when people do use the
bail system properly
in closing i just want to say this
no one gets a death sentence to be
served in county jail however from 2000
to 2016 new hampshire had 35 deaths in
our county jails
7 2016 alone our affiliate represented
one of those lives uh a pre-trial
detainee someone who was sitting in jail
only because he couldn't come up with a
hundred dollars and ended up paying the
ultimate price with his life
victims do occur on both sides of of the
walls
i personally believe a human life is
worth more than a hundred dollars so i'm
asking how many lies is this legislator
comfortable with allowing to pass away
while waiting to exercise their
constitutional given right i have to sit
in a cell because of their
socio-economic status
if the answer is none then i ask that
this committee vote itl on the on sb 92
and redirect our attention to utilizing
the bail system and the way that it was
designed to be used
i'm happy to take any and all questions
you may have
joseph uh first of all thank you again
testimony cheer recognizes
representative pantalakas for a question
representative
i'll never get used to these
thank you
thank you mr chairman i i just have a
question um mr lacrosse
could you tell me the person that was
represented in that jail
if he refused
fired his attorneys one right after the
other
um that is a great question i honestly
do not know the answer to that because
this happened before i was working for
the aclu um
but to my knowledge
we represented this individual
in his situation
thank you
[Music]
chair recognizes representative
testerman for a question thank you mr
chair
thank you for taking my question
uh
you really
you
you mentioned a fairly egregious
case
it was due to a hundred dollar bail that
they couldn't make
did the aclu or any of the contributors
say so you offer to pay that hundred
dollar bill i'm just if it's so
egregious
before you i'm not sure if the witness
can answer that question i don't think
he
speaks to me so you don't have to pass
it
no i i i i don't but what i did want to
say um
about that is one um to my knowledge we
weren't aware of his case that he was
sitting in county jail until after he
passed away um
but two also i think that
if you don't have the means
to come up with a hundred dollar bail
it's gonna be next to impossible for you
to get a hold of someone to come bail
you out because how are you gonna make a
phone call how how are you gonna reach
out of a county jail to and to to anyone
if you can't come up with that
yes when you're in county jail you are
charged for your phone calls
that that go out um and i and i and i
can say from personal experience it's
it's quite expensive
the chair recognizes representative
conley
for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you sir for
taking the question this still
contemplates a 72-hour
holding period
um is there any significance to that or
do you
you speak to what that
amount
thank you representative for the
question yes i can um
70 to a 72 hour time period
in a county jail is
a is that's a long time i i guess the
only way that i can um
try to accurately uh
um
you know give an analogy is like is for
anyone to think about the worst
situation that they have been in in
their life and then just imagine it
lasting for 72 hours straight um
that's that's that's how it is and in 72
hours if you are a person who's waiting
pre-trial you haven't been convicted of
a crime during that 72 hours you can
lose your job
you can lose your housing
you have dependents people who have
dependence on them people who are who
are who are you know their life is
depending on that individual that 72
hours can have significant impact on
people's um and that that i think is a
concern that can't be ignored because
that will that creates more problems in
new hampshire
as a whole
70s you know and and even more and i can
this is this part is on on my personal
experience but
county jails have been used as a means
to uh
get individuals to either plea out
quicker
um
and
that 72 hour period uh really does put
put down people people don't they don't
they don't want to be there they they
are
trying to get out of the facility and
that i i don't think that that is um
right to have people um
feel pressured into making decisions
just because they they want to have a
better quality
of life in the living environment
they're in
representative museum
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um you are the at
least the second person today who's a
member of the bail commission uh who's
come to testify in front of us against
this bill
what i'm wondering about is what the
status of the bail commission actually
is at this time
so are there additional meetings taking
place
are you reviewing legislation
it sounds like there was not an
opportunity to review this legislation
and i'm just wondering
where we stand right now in terms of the
bail commission which i understand is
legislatively required
yes thank you um
that's a great question um i the so the
aclu was the representative uh was
represented on the bail commission i
myself was not a was not the
representative or the member um
what the status of the bail commission
currently is i do not know the exact
status for you um representative muse um
i think i i i'm hoping that someone else
on the line will be able to give you a
more in-depth answer as to what its
status is currently is but i do not i
don't know if it is
still
together reviewing legislation or not
thank you
since you're in the room you're hard to
hear but i think i
i guess i did hear my name so
this is probably a pretty basic question
mr
cause but the the rationale for this is
that
some of these offenders uh
suspects are in fact actually are
dangerous um which obviously
so if if somebody eventually goes to
trial it's found to be dangerous and is
sentenced um doesn't the
time that they spent waiting
to be bailed out doesn't that count for
their sentence on when and if they're
finally uh convicted of a crime
um
so representative i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna repeat this back just to make
sure i understand the questions that i'm
being asked are you asking are you
asking me if um a person who has been
charged with an offense if their
pre-trial time counts towards their
sentence if they get convicted
yes
yes so that pre-trial time does count
towards a sentence if they get convicted
and but but that's the point it's if
they get convicted um
and you you don't know that until they
have their their day in court
great thank you just thought i just
thought i'd ask even though it's a very
basic very very basic question thank you
absolutely
seeing no further hands raised
joseph thank you again for your
testimony
thank you
if there's any members of the public who
wish to testify that are in attendance
that have not testified already
please raise your hand
seeing no hands raised
at this time
we will close the public hearing
let senate bill 92.
and mr chair on the on sb 92 there were
47 people who signed in in support of
the bill
and 81 people who signed in in
opposition
representatives
i'm you
mr chairman could you find out
where that bail commissioner report went
i was under the
assumption that
that commission would
put it into legislation
and i thought that was the only way it
would be done
the good news is that the vice chair is
a member of that commission what i
understand
could he tell us where it went
so far as i know
i haven't been reappointed to it
the commission still exists
and uh
but i haven't been meeting
oh it's gotta be started up again
further question to to the um
ice chair
did it was this put in any of this put
into legislation
i can determine what's in this bill was
not subject to the commission's
discussion
uh my share was correct
when he told you that they had
some proposals none of which are in this
bill
[Music]
would it be in another bill i mean i
don't mr cher
said
it wasn't right to do anything now
because it's only been seven months
but by now we should have legislation
i'm just wondering where it is
that's what we're trying to change
so i'm just going off of peer review so
i asked no one to take this
i know the difference
bill passed last turn
and
it was fast
and everything is
i think it passed in our
community so i don't know the effective
date of that
i don't know if that senate bill was the
byproduct of the commission's work
or not
but
when
mr chairman
no one else seemed to know about the
billiard dog
it was saying
what was the past that we were doing and
that's why he wanted to build change
in 92
and i i'm just curious to see where it
went
before this was implemented
that's my only question
right now we have another public hearing
i think
another one of those omnibus
yes
god
mr chair
yeah
i know what jeff bradley was trying to
do
but
putting these all together uh is
just not
the thing you're supposed to do you're
supposed to have some subject
close
and put things together that are close
to each other
but
like this next one it's just
in the meantime
uh
we can we'll be in recess though
thanks baby
questions
during the year
no difference now
[Music]
okay
that's
i did the same thing
really get pretty aggravated
together
the question i have for the sheriff
is i don't believe
anybody to testified
testified on section one or the last
section at all the only one that even
mentioned it was philosophy
that means you have two separate bills
that never got to hear
yeah it's a fair question
it is it's not a reasonable way to do it
it's kind of the whole idea of the open
forum new hampshire legislature
which is what it's been like ever
since here
if you had a chance to step testify on
everything
and i don't think anybody had a chance
to testify on section 1
i'm a little miffed
don't want to see it
prison
okay
thanks
um
[Music]
yes
and i'm like where'd she sit
[Music]
which one is
oh yeah
does representative muse have the
ability to mute the room
oh yes
did you get the
the link for this
caucus
check your email
um
room's on mute if the noise mentioned it
we can't hear you
the room is muted
that works can the members at home hear
us yes yes
right
well good afternoon everyone we're not
following you call to order the criminal
justice public safety committee
you will now open the public hearing on
senate bill 122.
[Music]
the sponsor is in attendance
well i will say uh
since my experience with the best time
for the senate and responsibility if
you are
not president they will introduce it on
your behalf
so is there a member of the community
that would
wish to introduce senate bill 1122
do you recognize representative true to
introduce senate bill 11.
excuse me
um
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee thank you for this opportunity
to uh introduce house bill
uh senate bill 122. for the record i am
representative chris
true representing rockingham district 4
auburn chester and sandown
i introduced senate bill 122 fn adopting
omnibus legislation relative to certain
crimes
and judicial processes and procedures
i believe we have people
more qualified than i who will be
testifying to answer any questions you
have thank you representative true
if there are any members of the public
that you should testify that are
independents
will the representative take a question
uh with representative finance
representative true was simply just
introduced into bill uh for procedural
purposes
and i understood that he wanted to yield
it yield any questions
he simply just introduces you
because
the sponsor of the bill is not as
intense
and i know i've personally been offered
the same courage by the senate so
i appreciate the weirdest off
the chair now recognizes
kyle morse
hi my name is actually sarah aiken i
work for a nonprofit so we share our
zoom
so i apologize that it has the wrong
name
um
chairman and members of the committee
thank you for hearing my testimony as i
said my name is sarah aiken and i am the
chair
person for the autism council
i come to you today only to speak on
part 5 section 2 of this bill relative
to the autism council
i
am not an expert in any other portion of
the bill so i will only speak to that
issue
we brought this bill forward to senator
bradley um
because in 2007 there was a bill senate
bill 138 that passed
um
i believe unanimously
in the senate and
overwhelmingly in the house to establish
an autism council
for the state of new hampshire for the
purposes of education resource
information and referral to families and
providers across the state around autism
services
this bill
here is just a technical bill
our
there are certain members who are
required to participate by this
legislation
in organizations that no longer exist
and for one example the autism society
was disbanded several years ago in the
state of new hampshire
and they are still required by law and
statute to participate so this is really
just cleaning up
the membership so that we can continue
to have effective meetings with a quorum
and
i'm open to any questions that you may
have but like i said this particular
section is just a technical
part of the
bill
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
up the representative
are you recognized thank you mr chair
and thank you ma'am for taking my
question
uh
you're talking about part five of the
bill we're talking about increasing
penalties
that's not a cleanup
um
sir the only part i was speaking to is
part five section two
like i said i i have no um background or
information on any other section
of this particular piece of legislation
i'm not here to discuss the service dog
issue in any way shape or form
because this is an omnibus piece of
legislation as you know there's many
different things put together i'm not
sure necessarily that this um this
technical change is
is best served in this piece of
legislation but here we are
and um
[Music]
and so i can't speak to the service dog
issue at all i must read that mr chair
i'm sorry
thank you man
certainly any time
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the winners
thank you very much have a great day
it's time to
cheer recognizes grant boss
mr chairman good afternoon and thank you
members of the committee my name is
grant bosse i'm the majority policy
director for the new hampshire senate
and i am here on behalf of senator
french and senator ward uh who cannot be
here to introduce their portions of the
bill i just want to um just as a
courtesy introduce them uh for you speak
very briefly on them and then take any
questions you have back to them
to get you an answer
on behalf of senator french speaking to
part one of the bill this was brought
forward last year and one was one of
many of the bills that were delayed
because of the covet 19 pandemic
senator french introduced this on behalf
of the merrimack county attorney who
asked him to bring the bill forward
again
currently any person charged with
violating any provision of rsa 265 a2
265 a3 or 265 a19 would be required to
complete an id cmp a certified drivers
training program if convicted of dwi or
dwi
and may register for such a program
after attending or waiving arraignment
in a criminal proceeding as part of any
sentence for dwi individuals have to
take classes often the trial can take a
long time to occur this would speed up
the time to get their license back after
revocation the state imposes again this
is allowing people to go about their
lives while they are
um
paying their penalty
and getting them back into their cars so
they can go back to work uh take care of
their kids that sort of thing uh i can
go section by section if you want i can
intro speak to all four sections if
you'd like that's up to you mr chairman
you may justify it as you wish
okay uh moving on to
section two from senator ward
this would provide exemptions from
prosecution for victims of human
trafficking again this is for minors
victims of trafficking 18 years of age
who is a direct victim of human
trafficking they would not be subject to
juvenile delinquency proceedings under
rsa 160b
for any otherwise chargeable offense
including indecent exposure prostitution
trafficking of persons or chargeables
attempt conspiracy criminal solicitation
being an accessory to or aiding and
abetting to any of these
offenses the bill also gives courts
guidance on how to handle these cases
senator ward worked closely with the
coalition against domestic and sexual uh
coalition against sexual and domestic
violence and the new hampshire voters
against human trafficking on this
version of the bill
and it's to apply only to the very
specific offenses that are a direct
result of being trafficked it does not
apply
to
any violent crimes or threats of
violence those should be handled
differently those are serious crimes
and being a victim of domestic violence
does not excuse you from prosecution
under them
but we think this is a good way to make
sure that these victims are not
otherwise victimized by the criminal
justice system and appreciate your
consideration of part
two i'm moving on to part three from
senator french this is a very uh simple
bill a consequence of americans living
longer it takes the uh guardianship by
grandparents currently in our laws and
extends it to also deal with great and
great great grandparents these are
obviously rare cases but
when possible for guardianship of young
children
we have a
preference in our law to keep it in the
family if possible this would allow that
for
these families across generations
and finally speaking for part four on
behalf of senator french similar to part
two
this is immunity from arrest or
prosecution for prostitution
for seeking medical assistance or
reporting certain crimes over the years
senator french has heard
uh
over the years from women and men who
were forced into prostitution they worry
about reporting crimes due to fear of
prosecution for their own activity this
bill would open it up and give these
women and men a safe path to call the
police to seek help to seek medical
attention
to report other more serious crimes
and to save lives without fear of
prosecution
uh themselves so that's parts one
through four of the bill on behalf of
our senators and i want to thank the
house for its consideration of senate
bill 122.
[Music]
thank you
chairman i
he said you you you're testifying for
uh senator french and
senator ward soon
yes and i i am not a subject matter
expert but if you have questions i can
take the questions to them and make sure
they get you an answer i'm trying to get
an answer are you going to testify
on the last
section section 5
uh no senator bradley has not asked me
to to do that um i'm
i was ready to address sections one
through four
[Music]
main requirements
and i want to thank you in advance for
taking my question
part four
when the effective date is
january 1st 2021 but
is
is that
similar to
house bill 123
i can check on that for you which house
bill was at again
123.
how's bill 123 let me check on that
and obviously as as bills move along
through the process sometimes effective
dates have to be moved back so
and just to clarify that that bill
passed by
it's now in the
initiating committee they already have
the hearing on it but the committee made
a recommendation i just i don't want us
to uh
get to our efforts
uh if you may report backwards if that
bill uh hosts the 123
test as amended
where they pass in the senate
um we would obviously
strike part four
yeah as i understand it the judiciary
committee held the hearing yesterday has
not yet acted on that i can check with
senator carson and see um
what the judiciary the spirit of the
judiciary committee is on that bill uh
and get back to you thank you very much
did you recognize representative for her
question
yes mr chair i just wanted to also uh
just start by pointing out that uh hb
123 the effective date uh as it appears
in on the gen court website the the
amended bill
is the same january 1st uh 2022.
my question uh for mr bossie is
um
can you
let people who may not be familiar with
the processes of the senate in the house
know why
a mirror version of a bill that we just
passed
earlier in the month
in the house
is appearing in a senate omnibus bill
and i'm speaking specifically of section
4 and hb 123.
uh well representative as you know any
any representative in any senator can
introduce a bill um in normal times
there's often coordination through ols
to try to winnow down uh similar bills
across chambers and with people working
remotely sometimes that doesn't happen
and this year in particular we've seen a
lot of duplicates uh sometimes even
within the same chamber you'll have two
or three bills with very similar subject
matter
and i think in several of your
committees you've seen that happen where
um there'll be several bills that
probably are getting at the same thing
uh and individual representatives or
senators had slightly different ways of
going about it so this was an idea that
the house had and pushed forward this
was an idea the senate had and pushed
forward they crossed in the night
they're now in the opposite chambers and
uh they seem destined for a conference
committee at some point um either
and it's just a matter of deciding which
vehicle is going to be the one that uh
the general court sends to the governor
but i don't think there was any specific
intention to have duplicates that's just
the way the legislative process cooked
out
representative recognized for a
follow-up
thank you
um
my understanding is that this was one of
the bills that
was passed last year in the house and uh
did not
was tabled in the senate uh because of
covet
um
one of the things that i'm curious about
is given the amount of elapsed time
and given the fact that the senate has
office staff that we don't have
necessarily in the house
how is it possible for a representative
not to be contacted
uh on a on a bill like this and looking
at the language of the of of section
four and the language of hb 123
um
they are identical
which
is doesn't indicate that two people had
an independent thought at the same time
so i'm just curious if you'd like to
comment on that
i couldn't comment on what senators were
thinking i think a lot of the bills that
were um
stalled before the finish line last year
came back
and and different people went to
representatives and senators and uh
frankly the coordination with people not
being in the building at the same time
uh during filing periods in november and
december
uh probably meant we had more
duplication than we used to have uh and
that's because bill's crossed chambers
you know we get to the point that uh the
house and the senate will eventually
decide you know which bill goes forward
thank you
there was two versions of the
phillymatic
if the house version gives a center
question
okay it's
in my short time here
so it's not
it's just tough for the witness to say
what the senators would think
i don't think that it's
if they cloned or copied uh
hp 123 that's a credit to
credit for the quality of hp 123. and i
hope that passes incentive
just a hint
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question back to senator french
because i did um testify in front of the
senate yesterday with this bill and he
had some tough questions for me so i
would like you to ask him
what
he has the problem with if he was going
to take the exact same language and put
in this omnibus bill if you could
um get more information on exactly what
his concerns are because i'm very now
confused myself since i've been
introducing this exact same legislation
two years in a
row i will check with senator french on
that representative
anyone else any members have any
questions uh unrelated senate procedure
representatives do you have a follow-up
question
i do not
and i want to thank you for this first
testimony
thank you very much i have a few
questions on house bill 123 that i will
check on and get that back
to the committee
thank you very much thank you
thank you um chairman i really do
appreciate it as again
uh if i could just speak real quickly i
was very confused when testifying before
the senate yesterday and senator frank
did have concerns with the bill so i'm
i'm now very confused
i'll have to play it back and watch it
all right the chair will not recognize
oh straight down shooting
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee my name is pamela kyleck
and i am the public policy specialist at
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence i am here
in support of sb 122
specifically parts two and four which
relate to exemptions from prosecution
for victims of human trafficking and
granting immunity from prosecution for
victims of sexual assault the coalition
did not initiate the bill but worked
with the sponsors and senate judiciary
committee to amend these two provisions
and we support the bill as amended thank
you so much for this opportunity to
testify today
just briefly on part two new hampshire's
human trafficking statute has
successfully worked to ensure that
victims are able to vacate certain
convictions for charges brought against
them as a direct result of being
trafficked while also upholding
important safeguards to ensure that
traffickers can be prosecuted for their
crimes as amended this bill maintains
that standard and will ensure that human
trafficking cases can be effectively
prosecuted while also recognizing the
complex and nuanced reality experienced
by human trafficking victims
in terms of part 4
as you noted the last speaker noted
section 4 is identical to hb123 a bill
that your committee previously supported
and helped pass the house we
fundamentally believe that the fear of
being arrested should never prohibit a
victim from reporting that they have
been sexually assaulted and this
protection should apply to individuals
who engage in prostitution
who are particularly vulnerable to
sexual violence
most importantly through the passage of
this bill new hampshire will be aligned
with federal policy and ensure
compliance with the violence against
women's act or vawa which prohibits
states from requiring a victim of sexual
assault to participate in the criminal
justice system or cooperating with law
enforcement in order to receive a
forensic medical exam or other
services that they're entitled to by the
state in conclusion sb122 is aligned
with our state efforts to support
victims of both human trafficking and
sexual assault and we urge the committee
to support this bill
thank you so much and i'd be happy to
answer any questions
thank you thank you for your testimony
seeing no hands raised the witness is
excused
hello hi
um thank you to the committee for
hearing my testimony thank you chairman
um i'm i'm my name's crystal de boras
i'm a social worker i've been a social
worker for over 20 years for people
who've been involved in the sex industry
a large proportion of those survivors of
human trafficking
and i have a national focus now i'm an
expert witness for the federal
government as well as the states of
minnesota california and new york i work
for a coup we
work with a couple of different
nonprofits and i'm here today with the
soar institute
which is based in brooklyn but we have a
national and northeast focus
pushing policy that helps survivors of
human trafficking
um in the northeast
uh i want to speak in support of sb 22
and speak a little bit more extensively
on part two
um
i've looked at both
the current vacator bill in new
hampshire hb 189
and
i think that this new bill puts new
hampshire um
in line with a more modernization of
vacator bills and makes it useful with
the for the lived experience of
survivors
as we know human trafficking is very
complex crime it takes numerous forms
and many survivors don't fit into a neat
story
that we would maybe read in a textbook
i consulted with the polaris project
which is a leading federal organization
on human trafficking
they
they run the national hotline they do
extensive research in human trafficking
and about a year ago they came up with a
report card for vacator bills
but right now they're about 29 states
that have these bills and they decided
to rate those bills and help to bring
all of this bills into a more modern way
some of them are quite old including new
york's the first in the nation
who's going through the same process
right now that we're talking about now
in part two um and unfortunately new
hammer new hampshire's score with
polaris was only 44 out of a hundred
rendering it almost useless uh for the
majority of survivors
and new hampshire survivors of course
deserve a 100 out of 100.
two of the most important aspects that
needed to be addressed are to
increase the eligible offenses
that are available to be vacated and to
have people victims of all ages qualify
to vacate their convictions
and just to close i'll tell a quick
story about one of my clients which is
really typical of the many many people
i've worked with who have been survivors
of trafficking over the years um very
typical story uh so just her name was
jessica and she was trafficked into
prostitution at the age of 23 by a man
who posed as her boyfriend and then
maintained control over her for five
years by using threats against her child
eventually she escaped and once she did
escape she had ten convictions for
prostitution and two for shoplifting her
trafficker induced her to occasionally
shop with items he used to make drugs
to avoid detection of the pharmacies etc
with the help of social workers in her
religious community jessica escaped and
secured her child's safety
and she really wanted to rebuild her
life and she wanted to join the
regulated work market she wanted to work
in her money and her dream was to become
a home health aide or a school crossing
guard those are the things she really
wanted to help others and give back
but both these fields
had job openings but she found quickly
that with her record she could not get a
job in almost any field that she was
interested in or any field that that at
all with this criminal record
she was able to vacate her conviction
convictions and she was able to get a
dream job in one of these fields
um
i i tell this story to explain exactly
how this law works and how it's
extremely important without vacating
this and she was an adult when she was
trafficked a young adult if she wasn't
able to vacate these she she would have
wound up in an unregulated work market
she would never been able to realize her
dreams or heal from her ordeal so really
express support for this
part two
um
finally i want to also express my
support for part four
as we have discussed here today this uh
this part has been discussed in other
hearings so i won't elaborate but i
strongly support in my many years of
um of working as a social worker with
these survivors that
they are afraid to come forward they are
afraid to to report some of the most
horrific crimes that are taking place in
our society and
it is really
on us
to create an environment where people
who want to report these criminals who
pose as the clients of sex workers to
come forward and get these guys off the
street so i really support uh part four
even though i understand we have all
discussed it before
thank you for hearing my testimony
[Music]
thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
thank the witness for a testimony
tuna recognizes
melissa or
[Music]
yes hi thank you so much for having me
testify today
um in support of sb 122 i will be brief
um especially since my co-director uh mr
boyce just testified before me but my
expertise is as an attorney an advocate
and i'm the co-director of the soar
institute
um with mr boyce and i had the the honor
of filing and winning
the first ever vacator motion in the
country since new york state was the
first state to pass such a law
and i have advised attorneys all over
the country legislators all over the
country
in terms of
having the most favorable vacator law
and favorable in terms of supporting
survivors of human trafficking
i strongly support
set part two
right related to exemptions from
prosecution for victims of human
trafficking that's the only
piece of this omnibus bill that i'm here
to speak about today
um
it really is so important
for survivors of human trafficking to be
able to move forward with their lives to
be able to obtain employment
um have their families intact obtain
housing and the way through that
is
through vacation
or um you know ceiling different states
of course call it different things of
their criminal record which continues to
settle them
with this insurmountable burden even
after they leave
um
even after they're able to escape from
their traffickers in fact i was just
called two days ago
by a former client of mine who i helped
to vacate numerous convictions uh in a
few different different jurisdictions
and she is about to complete her
paralegal certificate
and she would not have been able to do
so and to work as a paralegal
if she had still been saddled with a
criminal record so i urge you to um
to support this bill i'm happy to answer
any questions uh technical questions as
it relates to vacation motions i want to
make very clear
that these motions are
it's a pretty high burden for the person
coming forward to show that they are a
victim and to show that the convictions
arose as a result of being trafficked so
it is certainly by no means is it um
you know just a wide open door for
people to erase their records it is
quite it is quite a high burden
um but we should really allow everyone
that meets the standard to be able to to
vacate their convictions thank you so
much for your time
representative you're recognized for
your question
yes so thank you for taking my question
just a
a a quick hypothetical i'm i'm wondering
if
if a person who's a victim of human
trafficking
um
kills the person who's responsible for
trafficking her um
would that be
vacated under the bill that we're
considering now
you know that's a really important
question that were
you know in and
i am located in new york that we are
also grappling with in our quest to
expand our current vacation statute and
the answer is
potential excuse me potentially but with
a very very large caveat right that all
this does is allow that conversation
via the the litigation to occur
it is certainly by no means a stamp of
approval to vacate that conviction it
simply allows a court right a prosecutor
to hear the facts a judge to hear the
facts and to make a determination
based on a particular set of
circumstances so again look at it as a
way of
being able to just have that
conversation in a court of law it is
certainly not dictating what the outcome
would be
thank you
see you know for the hands raised
with us
thank you
jenna
recognizes brian donald
hello can you hear me
yes
excellent again my name for the record
is ryan donnelly i am an advocacy
coordinator with granite state
independent living
gsil is a statewide non-profit
organization that advocates and provides
services for seniors and people with
disabilities who wish to remain
independent in their homes and
communities and i'm speaking to you
today in support of sb 122 specifically
on part 5 section 1 of the bill which
enhances the penalties against those who
willfully cause harm to a service animal
i'm also speaking to you today as
someone who has owned and used service
animals in the past
i know firsthand the importance of the
work they do as do many of gsil's
consumers and staff who have also
benefited from the use of service
animals in their lives
these dogs are not just lovable
companions they are instruments that can
allow people with disabilities to live
fuller more independent lives and live
out in their community
if anything were to happen to a service
dog that made them unable to perform
their tasks that impacts not only the
animal but also places a tremendous
hardship on their owner
in light of this and in light of
learning that service animals are
offered no enhanced protections under
current state law to reflect the
important work that they do we ask that
this will be brought forward
under part 5 section 1 of sb 122
a person who willfully causes physical
injury to a service animal or willfully
allows his or her own animal to do so
will be charged with a class b felony
if the injury to the service animal is
severe enough that the service animal is
found by a traitor or veterinarian to be
incapable of returning to work that
charge will be increased to a class a
felony by enhancing these penalties
this bill will protect a resource
for people with disabilities that is not
only important for their independence
but also quite expensive with the total
cost of creating averaging to around
twenty thousand dollars
while it's true that a service animal is
not required to be certified or
professionally trained
most dogs are obtained through a
reputable organization that specializes
in training these animals alternatively
folks can find a professional trainer to
train a dog who has the temperament and
aptitude to be a service animal
such dogs are usually trained to the
standards of the international
assistance dogs association
on the flip side dogs who are poorly
behaved in public and are not trained to
assist their owner do not meet the
definition of a service animal under the
americans with disabilities act and thus
are not afforded the same protections
and considerations
with this in mind i hope the members of
this committee will choose to support sb
122. thank you for the opportunity to
testify before you today and for all the
hard work you perform on behalf of new
hampshire citizens
through you're recognized for my
question thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question
can you tell me is there a uh a legal
definition of what
a service animal is
there is a legal definition and that
definition is found in the americans
with disabilities act
um
essentially a
service animal again
they don't need to be professionally
trained or
certified
in any way
but the basic requirement is that a
service animal has to
perform
some kind of task
to assist
a person who has a disability
something like say
picking something up
that a person has dropped or helping to
open the door
things of that nature
thank you very much mr chair thank you
for taking my follow-up question
in new hampshire
uh the
this bill would have a class a felony
with a penalty
are there examples in new hampshire
where an owner of a dog intentionally
and locally
allows his dog to so a surface
animal that it would be a class a felony
i can't speak to any
specific cases but i can tell you over
the years
our organization has heard horror
stories
of incidents
where their dogs have been
harmed or
distracted in some way
sometimes
sometimes to the extent of
not being able to perform their duties
anymore either through physical injury
or
some kind of emotional trauma that that
makes them
unable to uh perform their work in
public
uh but again i i can't i can't speak to
any uh specific cases
thank you
representative welch you recognize my
question
yes uh
i'm aware that some people have
or i usually call it a therapy animal
would that be in the same class as a
service animal
a therapy animal like a
an emotional support dog of some sort um
i
i will admit i'm not certain
if that
falls under the same
definition
as service animal when we think of
service animals we
think of
an animal that that accomplishes a
physical attack physical uh
act task to
assist somebody with a disability again
uh
say i drop my keys on the ground but i'm
in a wheelchair and i'm not able to
reach down and pick those up a service
animal
uh could pick those up for me or if i
need help
getting into a building
a dog can grab onto
a rope handle and open the door for me
something like that but a support animal
whose
only function is to
just provide
comfort
for an individual i i don't know that
that's covered
you recognize represent representative
oregon for a question
thank you very much mr chair good to
well virtually see you ryan again um and
the question is about the the uh
the adjective willingly allow because of
her animal to cause physical immigrants
if you have a
someone else's dog attacking your
service dog um
so it
that seems to exclude
something that happens a lot where uh
you know the working dog is busy working
and they have a civilian dog who doesn't
understand and you know
i think that causes conflict between the
dogs especially
if the non-service dog is off leash so
so that you think that's the intent
behind the bill to not prosecute people
for those uh
for incidents like that or should i
absolutely absolutely i 100 agree with
that
okay sure that's why it's there okay
all right thanks
no i'm good he answered my question so
thanks i just haven't lowered my hand
yet thanks
there now i'm lowered thank you
for the hands right
i thank the witness for a testimony
thank you very much
if there's any members of the public who
who are in attendance that wish to
testify that have not
uh testified already
please raise your hand
this
did you really testify we you know did
this by a second time
staying over the hands raised
this time we're going to close the
public hearing on senate bill
20.
mr chair we had uh 16 people signing in
in support
of sb 122 and we had two people who
signed in in opposition
representatives
we're going to be in recess for about
five minutes but we may hold one
executive session
on uh
what'd you say okay
okay
oh
[Music]
yeah 338.
i don't know
it was raining yeah
what did we do
we passed it we did you and you
[Music]
that's true everybody just said it's
true
[Music]
and then they were like this is
oh
it's very interesting watching this from
afar
folks how do i look scott
no so
let's try
so
so this so now it's classy felony i
don't like this
all right did you eat in like 3 38
right
no yeah
all right so can we take it out
i mean i understand
it's maybe arguably apparently worse to
do with a
service dog so
from a misdemeanor to a class b
you know and if the first smith even if
the animal is
i guess put out a business it becomes a
class a
this is crazy
yes it is take this
look you think i'm supportive
it should be it should be the same
either way
it should i mean it's what could mean
class b or classes
all right even with that
that's why
i believe results
yeah we're going to just exactly
i knew scott was trying to sign in i
can't see him on my screen but there
he's on that on the big screen so we're
standing that three right
but because i said we were uh
i said we were that
there you go
looks a little gray there though
oh it's it's quite gray up here
please don't get disconnected
well what i'm just thinking of is
thinking a lot with senate bill 40
you know we won't do anything with that
for now we'll see what happens with
i believe it's hb 485 that was
represented
and we passed
they've already made a positive
recommendation
i just want to remind everyone if we if
there's amendments to any of these
ominous bills
only there has to be one amendment only
one amendment can be
adopted so we must
if there is something that's going to be
passed
we must work together
on we like working together or not it's
the only way to do it there's only one
amendment to come out
if you have an idea for a section
you know maybe we
you know
we'll see what we're doing
we're gonna find out what happened
it has to be amendy because it has the
wrong effect
sure so
oh
i remember it very well
it is to amend the budget last term
because the internet crimes against
children's division was defunded
it was a half million dollars i
believe that that was a very important
division to remain intact
i put amendments in i had four other
co-sponsors and i left some room in case
my friends across the aisle
uh cared to join me and post response
that amendment was essentially cloned
they changed one reallocation of money
which has nothing to do with the concept
the policy
then the order of business was changed
so that even though my event was filed
first
the other amendment
and despite my name uh not getting
credit for the amendment i still take
credit for the passage i raised the
agreement i got what i wanted
so
whether hb 123 passes i mean
we all deserve credit because we worked
on it
i'll get it right
i think i said something they stole my
participation
okay
for the members at home
while we're in the executive session
i
once
good practice to have it on advanced
at this time
we are going to open the executive
session
on senate bill 60.
representative conley you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
um and that is
the ideal
brings to light
a bigger issue and the people in favor
of marijuana
are trying to deduct this i think
yeah i somehow find an effort
to come up with a way to test
very quickly persons who are under the
influence
of marijuana
tried it by
training certain policemen
that probably doesn't work
i know it's been a different we've got
to find it
like a red light just to do this
[Music]
is
the fact that this was exactly
an asteroid
is important and i think
i think you all agree
someone who's
smoking and driving
at the same time
marijuana that's not
you know that's not that's that's
illegal and
it should be but here my
i couldn't get to the least successful
to the driver especially if you don't
have a trump
vehicle
my wife and i both don't have a trump
vehicles we have so
i mean you can be driving i can be
driving and someone saying the passion
who has
a prescription
but it's unsealed would have to put that
i'm not even sure where they would put
it
i think it's somewhat
subjective on what the least successful
driver is
so with that being said i
i i know there's a people who draw
that's an analogy to alcohol but a
bottle of alcohol
is usually
it's bigger we're talking about
something the size of a penny
they can be referred to it has to be put
somewhere else
so i don't
the fact that it's in the passenger's
pocket it's not okay to be there again
without having a
precise clear understanding of how this
can be
i i can't support it i just
i think i think that's that's a problem
and i i understand that this
has written is not being abused i'm not
saying the police would abuse it but
i know i i know just from reading it i
see some
problems here we would have to rewrite
the whole thing i don't think the policy
itself is the problem but
it can't be done this way i think we
have to separate then at the same time
now you have exceptions for bus drivers
taxis limousines i mean if i'm driving
someone's riding the patch ceiling for
all intents and purpose i am the tax
and somebody but there's no functional
difference i'm driving
the person's not you will you'll allow
an exception
yeah again i'm not
i have some concerns with that as well
i do i do appreciate there is public
safety concerns that we have to be aware
of you know i agree with representing
testimony
hopefully there's a field surprise
that's a reliable one that you come up
with
fast because
this is a publicity concern this issue's
not going away but i just don't feel set
up for 60 minutes
because when i first heard this bill
right off the back i just said that idea
and what really got me was i'm like i
know that we have different laws about
marijuana how much you have all those
types of
things to even drug dealers to actually
carry marijuana in the trunks and things
of this nature
broader than just what they were talking
about today i just thought it was
it was opening up the camera
but the way this was
worded and sealed and all those types of
things i felt that people could have so
much as they wanted
container you know pharmacy label on it
but if the seals the brokers open once
and that can be in your real consumer in
your pocket
but
the
marijuana can't
so
if
[Music]
again i don't
again there was a very short build i i
raised a lot of
it's an open container there's an open
container i mean it's pretty clear when
it's like a can of beer or bottle liquor
open container maybe not labeled
but it got their prescription medication
and
we passed a bill
for five years ago so all that people
that have been seated
although i don't have a medical card
again the goal here is well intended but
anyway
anyone wish to offer anymore
so you know for
seeing no further hands raised that
matter would not be the question
of the motion of the big speed
legislation please say yay
always please say thank you
hi
representative burke
representative popper yes
representative green
yes
representative wallace
josh
representative testerman yes
representative true yeah
representative pratt
representative marston yay
park votes yes representative perry
catherine yes
representative pantalakis
yes
representative ordnae
representative muse
yes
representative newman
yes representative horrigan
yes
representative conway yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley representatives
consent
mr chair was that 15-0
18. 18-0 thank you
for probably will you be preparing a
door to report
this time we will now
close the executive session on senate
bill 60.
we are